okay come on come on let's go
I don't know what's wrong it's not
working we're two minutes late here we
gotta go I know I said I know it's just
it's tricaster isn't working though okay
get it working it's not we're gonna have
to start late it's not gonna work all
right you know what to assume the
position
go
you found yourself at the junction where
worlds meet politics civility how about
honesty in this country Folks
Entertainment I don't
whole bunch of other stuff
you have a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body image not a
big Home Improvement Market in Detroit
we are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio's
strangest animals
[Music]
you're getting louder with Crowder
glad to be with you that is the sound of
the weekend that was my doggo Hopper
getting angered at the dancing even he
finds it offensive uh
lottery.com for all references I am your
host Stephen Crowder producing with me
in video Studio as always as Jared who
is not gay follow him on Twitter at not
K Jared I fulfill my legal obligations
dry on conclusions we good
yeah we're good internet don't you don't
sound like you're sure by the way if you
hear me drinking my beverage tonight
it's because not gay Jared had to remove
my mute button
something with it was going haywire uh
Big Show huge unbelievable the only way
to add such a big show we have uh NBA
superstar Andrew Bogut yep a little bit
of a bad boy
uh going to get personal there's some
back and forth that happened behind the
scenes that will will will bring you in
on the inside gag Andrew Bogut Austin
Peterson former libertarian candidate to
sound off on the debates from this week
Christopher Titus after the very heated
gun debate we're going to bring him on
in the last battles do happen he came
back he came back and uh we'll talk
about the Fallout maybe talk a little
bit about this election we have a few
segments we're also really Donald Trump
Donald Trump will be calling in in uh
toward the end of the program how do we
figure that one off the bat I don't know
how we forgot that one Donald Trump will
be calling in of course as you know he
generally calls in he doesn't do uh
doesn't do this video through the video
so we have that and then we'll be
debunking the Adam ruins everything
viral video about how a wall doesn't
doesn't help with immigration uh hint a
lot of it is untrue
so right off the bat though we did a
live stream during the debates this week
and uh you can tweet Us by the way at s
crowd if there are topics that you want
to hear I always forget to say that
because sometimes we forget some topics
where people really want some they want
to get some get some feedback get some
get some Shadows they won't get some
chatter going on
the debates occurred we live streamed it
I am astounded that we had like hundreds
of thousands of people just watching us
drink beers and live stream the debate
so we will be doing that if that's that
doesn't tell you about state of America
well apparently we made it palatable
um like we said during that that debate
live stream if you're looking for
cheerleading if you're looking for oh
damn Trump got you this isn't the
program for you uh here was my take on
it we did it in wrap-up thoughts I've
had some time to let it percolate
Donald Trump came out really strong
first 15 20 minutes and then ironically
enough didn't have the stamina to go
into those sort of Championship rounds
Hillary Clinton pulled ahead if you look
at the legitimate polls and focus groups
um I know you have some on the right
that you know you can't use Drudge
Report an online poll right just like
all these people used to say you can't
use the Ron Paul polls because they can
mobilize people online those aren't
scientific those aren't legitimate if
you look at the actual focus groups that
were run yes CNN over sampled liberals
but there were others overwhelmingly
people thought Hillary uh won that
debate however
however your honor Donald Trump stood to
gain the most because expectations were
so low for a lot of people people just
want
to have a reason to not vote Hillary
Clinton the people who haven't decided
yet and in this election that's more
than ever yeah in recent history they
want this just give me a reason to pull
the lever for Trump he had a good enough
performance to maybe get if either of
them are going to gain those undecided
people you know by a couple of points it
might be a wash and they might gain the
same amount of undecided people I think
what favored him was that his strong
point was at the beginning I think there
are probably people a lot of people who
probably thought you did really well
possibly tuned out before the second I
mean these are long debates it's
interesting that you say that because I
feel probably tuned out halfway if you
watch our lives and the people who are
tweeting us yeah they were at the
beginning they were going okay he's
going to be the next president and then
they were getting progressively
depressed throughout the debate my dad
and my brother who were doing some work
they tuned in about 30 minutes late
their you know their interpretation was
just oh my gosh Hill him off the floor
with him yeah so if you didn't see those
first 30 minutes it was an absolute
domination of Donald Trump if you only
saw those 30 minutes it was a domination
of Hillary Clinton if you saw it in its
entirety slight Edge Hillary Clinton
again not to me on here's here's the
problem with that too Hillary Clinton
I hate her ideas I hate what she stands
for everything about her but she's able
to articulate it pretty effectively in a
debate Donald Trump some of his ideas I
don't like some of them I really like
he's not able to articulate it that's
the issue so Hillary's issue she's able
to articulate crap and Donald Trump is
not able to effectively communicate even
if it's brilliant
um of course it helps because you know
she was sending Lester Holt signals
signals that's the nucleus seriously
sending here's the deal you don't need
conspiracies with Hillary Clinton
there's so much to actually go on now
we're going into Lester Holt
conspiracies that said it's really
really entertaining it is entertaining
and here's the illustrial was he biased
probably sure still not convinced he's
black uh Lester Holt probably biased but
you know that going in as a republican
you should know that and it's okay we
know it wasn't a Candy Crowley moment
did he ask more critical questions of
Donald Trump more questions personally
to Donald Trump than Hillary Clinton yes
you can look at those numbers however to
be fair Donald Trump didn't answer some
of his questions and if I were a
moderator I would have followed up too
yeah uh and Donald Trump did interrupt
Hillary Clinton a lot more than Hillary
Clinton interrupted Donald Trump so I I
think it was actually compared to like
the Candy Crowley situation compared to
what we saw with Romney Obama I I don't
think it was as bad as we've seen yeah I
really don't and I will say this one
thing I know people are going to get
really mad when I say this the the
no-fly no buy thing from Donald Trump
is as upsetting as any mistake he's made
where he said you know no if you can't
fly you should maybe nobody and people
say well he came with the caveat that
he'll make it easier to get off that
no-fly list here's the thing you don't
get to take away fundamental
constitutional rights whether you're a
Democrat you're a republican because of
some arbitrary list where you haven't
been convicted of a crime there's no due
process regardless of whether we create
an appeal process you don't get
and here's my issue with Donald Trump on
that the fact that he's gone back and
forth fourth two three times on that
people are gonna get mad you need to be
honest it shows that he doesn't
understand the constitutional right
it shows that he doesn't understand the
concept of you don't get to take away
rights because of political expediency
that really pissed me off and if you
look online on Twitter when people were
being honest if you look online as the
live debate was going on a lot of
conservatives were upset about that I
know you were too oh I was yeah I
couldn't believe it I couldn't believe
it I think he mentioned something about
the NRA even in there so you know he was
thinking thinking in a framework of this
is not what I'm supposed to say right
um and I think that's just I think those
are some things that just kind of show
not so much like a misstep that's just
kind of like I hate to say it I think
that the real Donald Trump kind of
leaking through kind of his is natural
bent and it doesn't mean that he's worse
than Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton is
abysmal I get it the problem is and
here's the problem with social media
right now the second I can see the lines
lighting up with people who are Furious
you know any criticism of Donald Trump
is going to put Hillary Clinton in
office no no listen you
two months ago were ranting and raving
about how great it was that Donald Trump
met with the nrfcom ar15.com or the live
chat occurs I know you guys are watching
you were just praising him by saying
well you know what it shows that he can
learn because he thought no fly no buy
and then he changed after his meeting
with the NRA for him to change back that
should piss you off and you should want
to keep him accountable and it's okay to
be critical on that that is a
non-negotiable issue you don't get to
remove fundamental birth rights the
right to protect yourself you either
believe in the Second Amendment or you
don't with Stephen Hayes with Ted
Kennedy I think it was Congressman
Clyburn all kinds of people have been
put on the no-fly list I know many
people who've been put on the no-fly
list
imagine that imagine you need to protect
yourself surprised you have to end up on
the no file list yet who knows it's been
a while since I've flown it has been I
Greyhound it with the retards
uh speaking of which while the debate
was going on meanwhile this happened
with Gary Johnson who's your favorite
foreign leader who's my favorite just
name anywhere in the country any one of
the continents any country name one
foreign leader that you respect and look
up to anybody mine was Shimon Perez no
no okay I'm talking about living no no
shut up
you got to do this anywhere any
continent Canada Mexico Europe over
there Asia South America
I guess I'm having an Aleppo moment in
the former former president I'm giving
me the whole world no I know anybody in
the world campaigns any leader
just say 10.
the worst the First new letting all of
the Islamic terrorist refugees for
record rape and record crime
I mean to say that these guys are like
Dumb and Dumber would be an affront to
dumb to Lloyd Christmas it would it
is unbelievable I think potheads deserve
a better representative than Kerry
Johnson it really doesn't seem like they
smoked himself silly this is not the
same Gary Johnson from uh was it 08 or
2012. uh
I don't remember gosh wasn't paying
attention that long just pick one let's
pick one just pick any in in in defense
you try to remedy with this tweet right
here oh he tweeted out it's been almost
24 hours and I still can't come up with
a foreign leader I look up to now here's
the deal if I understood like oh this
guy has just a fantastic sense of humor
you know what I mean I would say yeah
that was brilliant
I don't trust that that's the case with
Gary Johnson I don't think he has any
self-awareness no that's that cerebral
cortex where we had the doctor saying
you know that's the the one area that's
that can be altered by an incredible
amount of pots go home Gary you're high
you are it's over go home and here's the
thing with the libertarian party too
Gary this would have been an incredible
opportunity I don't think you should
throw away your you should vote however
you want right but let's be honest if
you're voting for Johnson you're
throwing away your vote it's a protest
vote fine do whatever you want but he
has a zero chance at winning we know
that
um but this would have been an
opportunity for the first time since
like Ross Perot to at least make their
voice heard if the Libertarians had the
fat naked stripper at the libertarian
convention uh the Chris Farley
Chippendales look alike would have been
more equipped to handle this election
more informed probably a little more
prepared
words coming a little faster to the
brain gosh Dave Rubin must be shooting
himself at the local gay bar I can't
imagine that he's handling this well and
I understand the spirit of it but he's
probably not because he has not gotten
the gun yet he has not gotten that gun
yet the gun we will be back to talk
about oh my god oh Emma Watson that's in
the dark little spare us
foreign
Clinton fact checks in real time that
didn't happen but should have these I've
these should have I can't believe these
didn't actually happen
Fair Point Mr Trump secretary Hillary
Clinton based on your health issues
Donald Trump has called your stamina
into question how do you respond well
as soon as he travels to 112 countries
and negotiates a peace deal a ceasefire
a release of dissidents and opening of
new uh opportunities in Nations around
the world or even spends 11 hours
testifying in front of a congressional
committee he can talk to me about
stamina okay um
weren't you spending 11 hours in front
of a congressional hearing uh because
they were investigating you
for felonies
that possibly killed people
that's us stay tuned for more fact
checks of Hillary Clinton in real time
that didn't happen to really state it
gets worse stay tuned
hey Jared what are you doing shooting
bad guys with what by AR-15 where'd you
get it
enunciate it more clearly so our
audience can hear
ar15.com that's better they sell guns
now yeah they do are they any good
they're the best we're from air15.com
you really make that sound did nothing
for sound effects
oh there's another one
you shot you shot with what AR-15 from
where
where hey how do you know they're bad
guys they're Redskins
that's racist
[Music]
foreign
all right glad to be back we have Austin
Peterson coming up after the break
libertarian candidate pick his brain
maybe talk about Gary Johnson or maybe
Maybe It's gotta have some thoughts some
words that has got to be a sore spot
some syllables to share
you know Austin Peterson uh obviously I
couldn't vote for the guy because the
open borders policy but I like him I
think he's a pretty sharp guy and for
him to lose a primary to a party that
won't even get 10 of the vote to a guy
who was effectively Cuba Gooding Jr's
character from Radio
is a really rough
pill to swallow it is that is a bitter
pill to swallow uh speaking of bitter
Lord gosh Emma it's Emma Watson right
Emma Watson who else am I thinking of
who was in like uh
that actress who was in Birdman
Spiderman Emma uh Emma Stone Emma Stone
two really generic you know what's funny
I can more easily remember ethnic names
like typical white guy or white girl
names really like Bob Jones I'm like
what was that Robert yes sure it's
really hard so Emma Watson Emma I just
forget Emma Stone Emma Stone Emily Blunt
Emily Blunt there you said you pronounce
your B like a fat guy blunt blunt sound
like someone who failed at trying to
skip stones so she went before the UN
here
and talked about feminism God bless her
turtleneck
um all right let's start rolling this
clip here and we'll just roll through
and pause it thank you all for being
here for this important moment these men
from all over the world have decided to
make gender equality a priority in their
lives and in their universities thank
you for making this commitment I can
tell you what those men look like I
graduated from University four years
this is too early I had always dreamed
of going and I know you started later
oh it gets into it okay all right all
right I just want to make sure we're not
wasting people's time because it gets
really bad and I want to get to that
quickly before I have an aneurysm I
don't want to go into a Hillary seizure
no no one needs it brown became my home
my community and I took the ideas and
the experiences I had there into all of
my social interactions into my workplace
into my politics into all aspects of my
life I'm sure you did yeah I know that
my University experience shaped who I am
yep and that's a problem of course it
does for many people she's right but
what if our experience of University
shows us that women don't belong in
leadership
what if it shows us that yes women can
study
but they shouldn't lead a seminar but
that's not shown anywhere in the
universe what if us still in many places
around the world many places it tells us
that women don't belong there at all
were you talking about like Saudi Arabia
what if as is the case in far too many
universities we are given the message
that sexual violence isn't actually a
form of violence pause
this is before the U.N
name one
name one University that is I can name
you 50 universities off of the top of my
head where gender studies are taught
rape culture is taught point me to one
University where the curriculum is
sexual assault is not really violence
101. name one they they Trot this out
and by the way they Trot this out to
demand International sanctions to demand
International globalist rule of law from
the U.N to take your rights away we'll
get into that later because the U.N
called for the United States to to give
reparations to Black Americans no word
yet in African nations who sold them
into slavery name one University where
rape is taught or swept on the wrong
name one University that teaches women
you're not allowed to be in a position
of leadership name one University that
is a post-adbanding safe space or
trigger warnings and checking your
privilege name one University that is
this Bastion of misogyny and rape
culture and inequality that
Emily what's your name Emma Emma Watson
is talking about see I can't even
remember her name she's so generic her
opinions are so pedestrian regurgitated
and she's right here's the thing she's
right the university does shape your
world view it absolutely does and she
went in there with none she was a girl
let's I'll get into this app because she
gets let's
go roll just go
but
we know
that if you change students experiences
so they have different expectations of
the world around them expectations of
equality
Society will change damn it as we leave
home for the first time to study at the
places that we have worked so hard to
get
we must not see or experience double
standards
we need to see equal respect leadership
and pay all right that's enough that's
enough I can't yeah so this is a stupid
person by the way fairness she spent 10
years in dress up and play with one so
that's gotta qualify for something yes
you're absolutely right here's the first
off pay this is a dumb person I don't
know why Emma Watson was like this meme
online that people find her attractive
or there's something about her that's
compelling I can't think of somebody
more ill-informed boring and bad at
their job she's right University does
shape their worldview and these kids are
going in it's an indoctrination Factory
where they're being taught false
statistics like you need to go before
the UN to demand more pay she couldn't
be more wrong and like you said this is
Emma Watson's greatest qualification to
have an opinion not saying she can't
have an opinion but she's sitting before
the UN who kind of screw up
international law a whole lot her
greatest qualification is she was a cute
if awkward unibrowed kid who was a good
enough actor for them to hand her
millions of dollars to take part in a
franchise before she even had her first
female cycle so this woman was
surrounded by piles of cash and here's
the thing she's talking about this this
will shape this will shape our world
view and people will have different
expectations that's true college does
shape your world view and people have
different expectations that's why you
have an entire generation of social
justice Warriors who get their teeth
kicked in by the real world because they
get into the real world and they realize
that it's not safe spaces and Trigger
warnings that's the same thing with her
here's the thing that people can
understand you know why this story
doesn't end well for most child actors
all of Hollywood is a safe space the
only place outside of University where
you have safe spaces and Trigger
warnings and precious is Hollywood why
because since Emma Watson has been a
little girl she has had her ass kissed
by agents managers publicists producers
directors who have a vested interest to
make sure that she does not face any
real adversity of any kind because they
need to protect their product and their
brand and so she's going to go out into
the world with unrealistic expectations
just like every child actor usually it
results in Coke off some broads hip
bones in this case it results in her
lecturing the UN and the rest of the
world on how we need to pay women more
and start treating rape seriously
all of Hollywood is a safe space
everything she said there is right
except for the facts on pay on a sexual
assault on violence against women but
the fact that University can shape World
Views yes and she is demanding less
intellectual diversity because she wants
to shape one worldview the worldview
she's had unchallenged throughout
Hollywood her entire career and
University I ca I've lost the ability to
even any Austin Peterson next
at Hillary's seizure it hurt
and now party conversations with Lester
Holt
oh my God no way no I assure you it's
true no you're joking no I'm not you're
joking right there's no way no I don't
believe you you should no I can't even
you should even I just
you're really black
I'm quiet this has been party
conversations with Lester Holt
[Music]
it's time for The Adventures of clock
boy and care
thank you
help me
help me help me oh is that poor man in
that building someone save him
have no fear wow clock boy that's
correct please there's not much time
save that man help me absolutely if I
can have just one
what are you doing clock boy I am
removing the internals of my Phillips
clock radio and I am inserting them into
this briefcase and how will that help
good question I am then going to take
this briefcase which clearly resembles a
bomb up until that Burning Man in the
building and when he points out that it
looks like a bomb clearly my sidekick
care will come in to sue him but how is
that helping it helps me a lot stay
tuned for more Adventures of clock boy
and Care follow him on Twitter he's
verified you know
foreign
[Music]
reach the wizard
there we go he's a gamer look he ran for
president but he can still have fun uh
Austin Peterson of course libertarian
candidate I'm sorry Austin I lost the
name of your website is it Liberty
libertarian
yeah the libertarian Republic the
libertarian Republic go check it out uh
he's been a friend of the show now as
far as the libertarian uh party ticket
you missed it by that much let's go
right into it Gary Johnson is there
um
what is Aleppo your thoughts
right bake the damn Aleppo
so yeah that that was obviously a big
stumble but it ended up being a good
thing not necessarily for Gary Johnson
but for I think foreign policy because a
lot of people started Googling Aleppo
right there everybody was like he was
like what what an idiot I mean everybody
was like well what is Aleppo right right
it was probably good to shine a light on
a region of the world that people need
to be paying more attention to but yeah
it was obviously a flub it got him a lot
more attention so I mean if uh if that's
what your metric is a success well then
I would say that that was successful for
him but uh you know he definitely needs
to brush up on foreign policy yeah he
does and potheads need a better
representative I will say that like he
get because he's not the same Gary
Johnson who was uh you know when he was
in office and now it does seem maybe
like he smoked himself a little bit
silly and uh they deserve better my lazy
pothead friends there is a difference
there is a different Gary Johnson from
2008 to 2012 not exactly sure what
happened I think that probably the
primary got him beat up pretty bad so he
may have come out of that a little bit
more bruised and then now he's got his
his VP Choice Bill weld that he's got
out there and so I mean yeah I mean if
you're a pothead then Gary Johnson is
your candidate and you know there's
nothing wrong with potheads I've smoked
marijuana and um you know I don't see
anything wrong with it but I think that
you know Gary Johnson definitely needs
to step up his game in certain areas but
well did you watch the debate the other
night well that was that was my question
because when we had you know you're a
Libertarian but you you had your issues
with Gary Johnson obviously the gun
issue with him he's remarkably
inconsistent the carbon tax that he
talked about he is just in an
opportunity a year where there's a would
have been a real opportunity for the
libertarian party he is just the worst
person to put forward right now so where
are you are you voting Gary Johnson are
you considering Trump where are you when
we're in this kind of circus well I'm
not considering Trump just because I I
worry about the rise of hyper
nationalism in the United States because
I think what that does is that leads to
things like tariffs that leads to
eventually it's the tax increases I
think I think that Trump he's supposed
to be the top Diplomat the top
Ambassador and Gary for all of his
faults I would trust him more as a
diplomat or Ambassador for our country
rather than Trump who seems to be a
little bit of a Loose Cannon and you
know did you hear I don't know if you're
today Barack Obama came out this week
and said that don't vote for Gary
Johnson because that's a vote for Hill
for a vote for Trump and all that's
funny because all the Trump voters say
that a vote for Johnson is a vote for
Hillary so I can't decide if by voting
for Johnson I'm voting for Trump or
Hillary so it's a little confusing uh
but I I personally prefer Johnson to
Trump or Hillary I think it comes down
to are you terrified you know do you
find the prospect of a Hillary Clinton
presidency terrifying enough that even
if you're a Libertarian or third party
you don't like them that you say all
right I can't allow it in which case you
vote for Trump not Johnson because we
know you know Johnson doesn't actually
really have a chance of winning the
election it depends on how terrifying
the idea is of a Hillary Clinton
presidency I think that sort of
determines who you think it could help
more
well I'm a little bit more strategic
when it comes to that maybe I'm I want
to get in trouble for saying this but I
kind of come from the Alexander Hamilton
Federalist wing of the libertarian party
and Alexander Hamilton made the argument
that it's better to have someone who uh
at the top of the ticket or excuse me
for in the presidency that you did not
support that you are not responsible for
because that way you can oppose them and
if the if the candidate is Hillary
Clinton then I think that the
Republicans and Libertarians and
conservatives we would all finally be
United again against a common enemy and
that way we're not responsible for what
Hillary Clinton does if Donald Trump
wins then the Republicans and to a
smaller extent some conservatives are
responsible for what Donald Trump does I
would quite frankly like to see
conservatives and Libertarians start
getting back together and working
together again well why haven't they
been under eight years of Obama why
would it take Hillary Clinton uh you
know for them to be the opposition party
well I don't know that we've necessarily
been
um there hasn't been that much disunity
over the last years when it comes to
Obama so and here's the thing the Cato
Institute actually published a study
about divided government and what they
what they found was when they analyzed
uh government spending is that and
government growth Democrats president
and Republican house I think
exactly if you have a republican House a
Republican Senate with a Democratic
president historically the growth of
government has been the least right
government always grows the government
is that that's the trend but it grows
the least when you have a Democratic
president with a Republican Senate and
House I don't know if we're going to be
able to maintain the Senate house uh but
I'd like to see us gather together to
build the coalitions that would make
that necessary well and for all of his
his sort of protectionist policies which
we've talked about you know Donald Trump
he did come out and say this week he
said he was going to cut the federal
government by 25 right away
um that's far more drastic in the sense
of downsizing government than anything
Gary Johnson has really put forward so
as a Libertarian what's your reaction to
that or you just think well it's it's
hot air well I think it's hot air and
the reason why is because if you
remember before
um before George W Bush was elected he
wanted to make sure that the United
States was not the policeman of the
world but then when it came down to it
he did the opposite and we actually have
seen Governor Gary Johnson govern we
haven't seen Donald Trump government so
we don't actually know if Donald Trump
would put his principles into practice
whereas we actually do know what
governor Gary Johnson did in New Mexico
and that was to cut spending cut the
budget and he governed much more
libertarian than any other governor in
history I think saves maybe one or two
well okay so you talk about you know not
being responsible for them but like you
said Republicans and Libertarians have
been United under Obama and what's that
gotten them nothing so this is this is
the argument from the other side of the
coin
um
saying you're not responsible for
Hillary and I understand that and I
understand you do have to vote your
conscience I understand I could never I
could never ever ever vote for Hillary
I've always said Trump has two election
day uh to convince me
um I've tried to support him I think
he's right criticism where I think it's
fair that's what I've tried to do that
being said if you don't if you you vote
for anyone outside of trump against
Hillary because like you said you don't
want to be responsible for is there some
aspect of your kind of playing chicken
with the United States of America at
that point
uh it depends I mean if you're talking
about the federal election and the broad
sense like the a single vote is uh
almost infinitesimally small in terms of
the impact what you really need to be
focusing on are the local races and
remember the president whether it's
Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump they
only have a certain amount of power they
only have a limited amount of power so
if you really want real change you
should be paying to what's going on in
your local elections because Donald
Trump or Hillary Clinton either one of
them they'll both have the same amount
of power
Supreme Court though I mean that is one
thing that is up in the balance
especially as a second amendment person
I know you are I know I know Gary
Johnson not as much
um that is I mean that's gotta keep you
up at night right with that that is for
me I'm like gosh a supreme court Heller
the Heller case
I I can't see not weighing that as
heavily as anything I've I've done in my
political lifetime right but the only
problem with that is is that Republicans
don't have a very good track record of
picking conservative judges either I
mean who was the the Supreme Court
Justice that gave us the Obamacare
decision that codified it right that was
a republican pick under George W bush
right there was a federal federal judge
by the name of Richard Posner who said
that the Constitution doesn't really
apply anymore he was nominated there by
Ronald Reagan so we haven't really had a
good history of conservative judges
being picked necessarily by Republicans
either I do think on the Second
Amendment yeah I think the Second
Amendment is such a strong issue and in
Republicans for for all their faults
have done a good job of keeping their
feet to the fire I don't think you'd
have a Republican or conservative
Supreme Court Justice who would say that
private citizens have no right to own
firearms at all which is what the
dissenting arguments right where a lot
of people don't realize what the Heller
case it wasn't uh capacity uh limitation
or it was you don't have the right to
own firearms in the United States which
is insanity the arguments against the
current ruling is way more important
that even though he ruled you know in
favor all right and well in some
consider would say that the decision to
uphold Obamacare was would lead to the
death of Obamacare and in some ways it
has because we've seen that a lot of
these people have been pulling out the
exchange has been pulling out right I
think Edna pull out pulled out so so
there is some there is a very good
argument for that as well so you make
good points gosh yeah so so you are
gonna pull the lever for Johnson
yes I'm going to be supporting
supporting for Johnson I'm all I'm all
in for Johnson even though he got all
and sniffy with you on Stossel he
has been so horribly rude to me and uh
he threw out my gun that I gave to him
as a gift but he gave him a real gun as
a gift well it was a replica of George
Washington's flintlock pistol actually
got it right here but he threw it in the
trash it was a big huge dust up it was
an argument because because we we had a
pretty nasty primary but yeah I did
endorse him anyway but uh he did that in
front of you or did he like send you a
letter I through I threw out your gun
Austin uh somebody saw him do it and
they pulled it out of the trash and gave
it back to me so Donald Trump may not be
the most Petty person on that stage
maybe not but here but here's the
problem the problem is nobody's going to
give a damn about my ego in four years
10 years 18 years you know I have to
think about what's I have to do what's
right you know more than just care about
like you know people who insult me or
slay like me I have to pick who I think
is the best candidate no matter what a
jerk they may have been to me that's a
good way to look at it and I wish that
uh Cruz Trump Rubio all of them were
able to to do that and I think the
problem is they've been so to this
divisive I think they've been so
personal in their attacks it's really
hard to get a lot of people coming over
that side and that's where Donald Trump
you know he can't get over the hump of
enough Republicans it's not when they
were Democrats it's enough Republicans
because you know listen it's one thing
to say my opponent was in the gang of
Aid or supported some kind of
immigration bill that I don't like it's
another to say as Dad might have killed
JFK it's hard to bring them over yeah
yeah you could say that I mean it was a
bitter fought primary and you know Ted
Cruz's endorsement was rather tepid last
week so I that's why I think Trump is
probably not going to win because
Hillary's base is solidified Bernie
Sanders endorsed her uh and the
difference is that with with Cruz it was
much more of a wait and see and a last
minute thing so I see the Republican
party is in chaos right now but if the
Republican Party gets destroyed and if
Trump loses that could be a good thing
for the Republican Party going for
forward because that would show that the
the conservatives had the right argument
and that Donald Trump and the
nationalists and the populists are not
going to be the future of the Republican
party because I mean do you really like
Trump that much I mean I mean he's not a
conservative by any measure he's kind of
a liberal Republican and you know kind
of a Rockefeller Republican in many ways
but the guy doesn't even have any real
true philosophy or ideology so I don't
know that uh him winning is necessarily
a good thing for the Republican Party
either I think that it probably sets the
conservative cause back decades and I
understand that argument Ben Shapiro
makes the argument there's no reverse
gear I would say this it's easy for
people like us who are who are so close
to think that it's all this sort of
nationalist populism the vast majority
of trump supporters aren't that I think
the vast majority of trump supporters
are people who've been lifelong
Republicans or people who feel like
Republicans haven't gotten anything done
I think you have allowed contingency
online who have Pepe the Frog swastikas
I was gonna say what about the racist
fraud yeah what about the races and
believe me I get them I get pictures
sent of me and gas Chambers and it's
like well I'm not even Jewish but I
guess they think that I am and I get
abort those people are terrible I don't
think that's the biggest base voting for
Trump
um so I you know I understand what
you're saying but I don't necessarily
think that it proves conservatives right
if Trump loses it may just prove sort of
the Republican party is irrelevant there
are several ways to look at it and I
just I really I mean Hillary Clinton
would be so disastrous at this point I I
just I don't know where we are as a
country and it seems like we're playing
chicken only you know Hillary's the only
one driving us off a cliff sure but
she's much she's very much an
opportunities opportunist just like her
husband is and I mean think about what
happened when Bill Clinton got destroyed
in his midterm when he was Assad
re-election I mean that that guy became
a conservative pretty darn quick talking
about welfare reform I mean Bill Clinton
is the guy that originally said that he
didn't want to regulate the internet
that the government should be if there
was a Democrat running just because he
wanted the weirdest porn to stay up
that was Anthony Weiner so Anthony
Weiner was the one uploading the porn
exactly they're in cahoots but um no I
think that I think that when it comes to
Hillary Clinton she's much more of a
moderate Democrat you know she's not the
kind of like I don't think she's even as
much of a rabid socialist perhaps as
Obama is so I as bad as she is I think
that when it comes to the differences
between her and Trump there really
aren't that many big differences they
agreed on a lot of things the other
night Donald Trump saying hey if your
name is on a terrorist watch this
sorry bro I know I know you were talking
about the Second Amendment you know the
government oh I know
I'm not a huge Trump I'm not a huge
Trump fan I was totally against him in
the primers I just think we're at the
point now where the gravity of the
situation with Hillary Clinton I don't
know well let's stay on this when we
come back and we'll also talk about Fox
News and Roger Ailes grabbing our butts
little known fact Austin has a great
butt and it's irresistible it is
actually yeah we'll be right back
yes stay tuned
[Music]
and now Hillary Clinton fact checks in
real time that didn't happen but should
have these I've you should have I can't
believe these didn't actually happen
race
remains a significant challenge in our
country
unfortunately Rey still determines too
much often determines where people live
determines
what kind of education in their Public
Schools they can get and yes it
determines how they're treated in the
criminal justice system we have to
restore Trust
between communities and the police
we have to work to make sure that our
police are using the best training the
best techniques that they're well
prepared
to use Force only when necessary
everyone should be respected by the law
and everyone should respect the law
right now that's not the case in a lot
of our neighborhoods so I have ever
since the first day of my campaign
called for Criminal Justice Reform I've
laid out a platform that I think would
begin to remedy some of the problems we
have in the criminal justice system uh
okay I know you need the the black vote
now desperately but um isn't that an
about face
considering your husband's
Administration incarcerated more black
people than anyone to come before him
the three strike rule
it's one of the reasons black people
hate you
kind of
hot sauce
seems obvious but no one said a thing
before you kill yourself stay tuned for
more fact checks with Hillary Clinton
that should have happened
but didn't damn it
[Music]
glad to be back Austin Peterson uh
libertarian candidate uh the
libertarianrepublic.com he is here with
us uh cute guy great guest glad to have
him on the program here's the deal I
understand everything you're talking
about but the people who a lot of people
who are Libertarians will get aggravated
that you were far more critical of trump
just now and a little more forgiving of
Hillary even though there aren't maybe
as there isn't a stark of a contrast as
either one of us would like I can
understand people being like well it
seems like these people want Hillary
Clinton to win just so they can be
proven right
ooh yeah not me uh the the problems that
I have with Hillary are numerous and
she's talking about mandatory
um you know uh paid time off but so is
Trump she's talking about people not
being able to have their guns if they're
put on Tara's watch list but so is Trump
so that's the problem is is that it's
much easier to criticize somebody
because with Donald Trump again with no
legislative experience with no governing
experience he's more of that wild card I
mean with Hillary at least you know what
you're getting right it doesn't mean
that I support her that I'm like easier
on Hillary Clinton it's just that you
know you give up on the Democrats you
have hope for the Republican but when
you have no hope for the Democrat it's
just a waste of time really criticizing
them because pretty much everything that
comes out of the mouth you're going to
disagree with accept except for the stop
and frisk issue which I do believe is
unconstitutional and an abrogation of
our fourth amendment rights and that's
the thing that Hillary Clinton is more
libertarian than Trump on yeah so you
know that's that's the problem is that a
Libertarian looks at both sides of these
things and says you get something with
this candidate and then you lose it with
the other other candidate so it's it's
really just a wash well In fairness I
think Hillary that's a that's a that's a
race try to pick up a few more votes
with that issue that has nothing to do
with the principle I don't think yeah
she's like I can win back the negroes
with hot sauce and being against stop
and frisk
sure but why do you think Donald Trump
takes any position that he takes like
being against the Iraq War for example
do you think that he does that because
he would he thought it was a wrong
decision no because as soon as it became
politically expedient to be against the
invasion of Iraq that's the position
that Trump took so you could argue the
same thing I think he was against it for
a long before it became really popular I
would give him credit there the Howard
Stern thing notwithstanding that was
kind of off the cuff I would give him
credit as as someone who I remember him
and Hannity arguing a while back when
Hannity was still pro-iraq war a lot of
people at Fox News I think Trump's been
pretty consistent on that okay well I
mean okay let's say you give him that
but I mean the question is do you really
believe him and do you think I mean
Trump strikes me as the type of guy who
would be willing to intervene around the
world he strikes me as a rather hostile
character his temperament you know
that's the problem yeah okay you want
somebody she's the one who has a
temperament that's unfit I've got the
great temperament okay and the stamina
he's got the stamina uh
I know I can't believe that we are here
uh I do think listen when it comes to
the Supreme Court I think that's
important I think he'll be better when
it comes to taxes I think he'll be
better I do think he'll probably uh cut
down the size of government to a degree
I I don't think he has a fundament and
this is where isms matter a lot of
people say oh I don't believe in any
ideology well that's silly everyone has
an ideology you just need to be honest
about it the ism of you don't get to
take away someone's fundamental
constitutional right because they were
put on an arbitrary list even if you try
to hedge it with but we'll make it
easier for them to get off it doesn't
matter if they haven't been convicted of
a crime they don't lose their rights and
that's someone who doesn't understand
the concept of a he not a civil right a
human right it's an individual right to
bear on arms and a lot of people will
say when they criticize the Second
Amendment they say well what about the
militia Clause well if you actually go
back and you read the Constitutional
debates George Mason who is George
Washington's hunting buddy said that I
asked her what is the militia yeah it is
the whole other people except for a few
public officials so that it means that
it's an individual right to bear arms to
the citizens and those are the type of
rights that we need to be defending but
Donald Trump is not a defender of the
second amendment by any means uh but I
think again with Donald Trump he is so
beholden to p on the Second Amendment
issue that his feet can be held to the
fire and I don't think he'll do anything
it would be anything other than Pro
second event whereas Hillary Clinton
she's so beholden to donors and so
beholden to the the Mom's demand action
that I think she would go as far left as
she could on gun control which I think
would probably make her a one termer
because that's the single losing uh
losingest issue to use the word uh of
Democrats but I do think that would be a
big difference well what would be better
to have two terms of trump or one term
of Hillary don't you think that we'd
probably be better off with one term of
Hillary or yeah but what if what if the
Muslims come to my house in that one
term I'm not willing to roll the dice
with it I I need an AR-15 and screw you
that's my opinion well you can have your
AR-15 and that's the thing is but you
have to vote for Gary Johnson
[Laughter]
of Hearts you said
Gary Johnson's not going to win we know
that uh so you vote for Gary Johnson
election day comes out in your heart of
hearts do you feel better about the
country if they say a new president
Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump
uh I don't feel good either way and I'm
I'm being intellectually honest here too
and I'm not trying to I'm not trying to
dance around no no I believe you I have
really big problems with both of these
candidates otherwise I would support
them if Rand Paul had won I would have
never I would have never gone and run
for president in the United States as a
Libertarian I would have been supporting
Rand Paul all the way if Ted Cruz had
won this would have been a much more
difficult situation for me because I I
ran because I thought well there's no
way I think Trump was absolutely going
to win and so it was for me it was it
was a chance to give voters an
opportunity to vote for someone who
actually does care about the
Constitution but these this these two
candidates neither one of these
candidates are have any Fidelity to the
Constitution so the Republican Party
screwed up big time but you may have
just tipped your hand because you said I
thought Trump was going to win a lot of
people saying ah don't worry he'll
fizzle out is that because you and I you
know we both worked at a former uh news
agency and you know the inside baseball
and yeah Roger Ailes is now working with
Trump yeah did you know that all along
we're like oh he's gonna get a push yeah
of course because they've those guys
been buddies for years and years and
Donald Trump's on Fox and Friends every
morning their highest rated show the
capable Morning Show and so it was
pretty obvious because you know it's
it's called The Fox News primary for a
reason you know if you do well if you do
well on Fox then you've got it in the
bag you know were you just laughing
internally we were when everyone's going
oh boycott Fox because Megan kelly
didn't like uh Donald Trump were you
just laughing at the implosion oh yeah
oh yeah and it's amazing what's happened
now because here we see if Donald Trump
loses the word on the street is is that
they're going to start a rival news
organization and combine forces with
Breitbart to go ahead and try and
compete against Fox News and remember a
lot of our former colleagues had
contracts like Sean Hannity that had
gave them outs if Roger Ailes is not the
head of the institution Bill O'Reilly
might retire Megan Kelly might leave uh
Greta Van Susteren she's gone man she's
gone yeah I saw her I saw her on
Facebook like three weeks ago she did a
live stream and I there's a lot of
weirdness going on with that because
it's almost seemed as if she didn't want
to do that because she was on on
Facebook she looked real unhappy she's
like well I just want to keep doing the
news and so I'm going to start doing
live streams on Facebook and stuff and
I'm like damn and that's new and
improved Greta with the base work uh
Austin Peterson the libertarian
republic.com everyone but we'll have to
have him back because we always last
time we got into a fight on the border
uh but I love what he has to say I hope
he keeps shaking things up stay tuned we
have Andrew Bogut coming up soon right
yep oh gosh I don't know the or oh I
don't even know him but Jared's a fan
stay tuned stay tuned
[Music]
and now Hillary Clinton fact checks in
real time that didn't happen but should
have these I've you should have I can't
believe these didn't actually happen
all right cyber security uh Mr Trump
calls it the cyber
Hillary Clinton go well I think cyber
security cyber warfare will be one of
the biggest challenges facing the next
president because clearly we're facing
at this point uh two different kinds of
adversaries there are the independent
hacking groups that do it mostly for
commercial reasons to try to steal
information that they then can use to
make money and do you think we need to
make it very clear whether it's Russia
China Iran or anybody else the United
States has much greater capacity and we
are not going to sit idly by and permit
state actors to go after our information
our private sector information or our
public sector information right and do
you think that um
using private servers to send classified
emails from your basement would make
America on a cyber security level more
or less safe
that make us more
or less
hot sauce stay tuned for more fact
checks of Hillary Clinton in real time
that didn't happen no really state it
gets worse stay tuned
[Music]
here we go
I am tweeting out that we are debunking
the atom ruins everything because people
are asking us
on the border wall I'm tweeting this out
right now you can hear me second hour
for those listening to rest really not
gay Jerry illegal obligations all that
stuff all that good stuff about the
obligations all right there Austin
Peterson uh cool guy actually it's
fitting that it follows because uh he's
a big proponent of sort of immigration
that's why I can't get on board with
someone like Austin Peterson this
multiculturalism this feigning sort of
oh who cares about the borders and
immigration is great for the United
States not as it exists and I I
sometimes I think that I'm not saying he
does this but when people on the right
who are trying to Virtue signal with
that stuff they're being intellectually
dishonest uh the current state of
immigration with the United States
illegal immigration with Mexico is a
horrendous problem everyone knows it uh
that's what is really that's the single
issue that is helping Donald Trump
that's the biggest issue helping Donald
Trump is that people think he'll do
something about that people are because
I think more people relate to that even
more than like the trade issues and
things like that things people seem I
think as general lesson formed
they kind of grasp the whole immigration
problem better than well the general
populace yeah General populace they're
not super not necessarily Trump voters
but Hillary voters the general voting
doesn't know a whole lot about trade
policy doesn't know a whole lot about
the tax code beyond what affects them
directly but there's so many day-to-day
interactions with the you know the
immigration situation especially in
southern states people are frustrated by
the way uh Andrew Bogut will be on next
and um Christopher Titus Christopher
Titus and Donald Trump himself Donald
Trump himself LeBron James got into hot
water this week let's just hit these
really quickly because he said all lives
matter was entirely reasonable he said
hey uh my we'll talk about that with
Andrew Bogut anyway see what his opinion
on the outrage is silly Ben Shapiro is
being sued by clock boy
he is truly sorry the gift that keeps on
giving Ben I feel I feel because that's
gonna be expensive it will be yeah so
Ben I'm not making light of it I feel
bad for you
but that is hysterical and of course
that's all he does is Sue that's all the
kid knows how to do is for all I know oh
I know we have a lawsuit on us yeah we
couldn't make it to the PO box that's
okay you have no idea so uh we don't
have a ton of time so this video is
going viral right now I want to get to
this first Adam ruins everything as a
show I've actually really liked that and
ruins everything on quite a few things
I've taken some sort of I guess
libertarian stances sometimes they're
kind of social justice left us but
generally speaking it's it's pretty
informative
um this is one where they were
completely wrong and not even realizing
how wrong they were comes from College
Humor it's a show on what is it what's
the network it's also on TV I think it's
on True TV True TV one of those kind of
Hotel only stations yeah I don't think
many people watch and uh well
if you're listening to it it could sound
plausible what he says but I've got some
information here that might just smack
you over that so let's roll the first
clip
building a wall would actually increase
the number of illegal immigrants in
America nope what how could it possibly
here I'll show you
and he goes on and he goes on from there
so first off that is not true let me
tell you something here a book that I
recommend it's up on my page stolen
sovereignty how to stop unlike the
judges from transferring America uh
Daniel Horowitz uh forward by Mark Levin
he talks about illegal immigration quite
a bit in a way that is is very
informative and very enlightening so I
would recommend uh putting that in your
in your reference book uh do we have the
first clip where he talks about the
percentage of immigration is that the
first clip uh I think the first one is
NASA
between 27 and 40 of all undocumented
immigrants in America came here on
planes
okay
here's something and that's just said so
flippantly right oh building a wall
because 27 to 40 percent of the are
people coming on planes it goes on to
say overstaying their visas got it
have you done the math yet
that means at minimum 60 of illegal
immigration doesn't occur
from Planes and visas
someone called it a majority up to 73
percent
at least not planes and Visas so here's
the deal does it mean that a wall will
fix everything no one's saying that but
if you could have some sort of an effect
on let's use the most conservative
figure 60 of illegal immigration by his
own admission how is that not
significant enough to build a wall
this is what the left does they try
again it's just one of those things like
Anthony cumia was saying was well you
think a wall is going to do anything I
think it's going to do anything if it's
only 60 to 73 of illegal immigration
yes I do I think we should if you had
Joe Rogan talks about this if you had a
ham sandwich that was 60 crap and 40 ham
you'd probably want do something about
the crap it's still 60 crap so the
number there right off the bat almost
hot dogs that's just true
um the number right there right off the
bat should concern you
it debunks the entire argument if you
believe that even curbing that pesky
little 60 to 70 percent is worthwhile
you don't even need to watch the rest of
the video I do I assume many of you do
let's assume you say you know what I'll
give them 60 to 70 percent
continue next clip it would easily be
one of the single most expensive pieces
of infrastructure in American history
costing as much as 20 Hoover dams or
NASA's entire annual budget
just an annual budget so not that just
one one annual budget
this is supposed to turn us off I say we
turn NASA off for you just turn NASA off
just the wrong for a year like the UN
will do with the internet yep throttle
it a little bit and just start putting
up the wall
it is unre that's not that expensive
particularly when you look at the
economic ramifications positive ones
when you stop illegal immigration next
clip even by your estimate a Visa
overstays the wall would still stop
about half of America's 11 million
illegal immigrants no it wouldn't
because of a little something called
circular flow here I'll show you
incorrect I'll tell you why keep going
for decades immigration to the U.S was a
circular flow people would come work for
a bit and then after they were done go
home to their families
uh a that's not entirely true and B
that's morally reprehensible that was
never what America was intended to be it
wasn't intended to be a revolving door
so people could come in abuse a system
and leave you don't come to a country to
drain from the country to send to other
countries that's not how a country works
that's not being ethnocentric that's not
being xenophobic that's called having a
country okay
something else
um
it's very different this is the thing
with Austin Peterson Libertarians the
revolving door they talk about people
coming in revolving door to work and
send back benefits a that's not right
you don't get to do that you move here
legally period right we've already
covered that but the revolving door for
work is very different from a revolving
door for entitlements people are going
through the revolving door right now and
not paying for health care and not
paying taxes and getting all of the
social benefits the benefits from the
social safety net from hard-working
Americans that's the it's never supposed
to be a revolving door and it's worse
now because a lot of illegal immigrants
aren't really coming here to work not
all of them but many of them are coming
here and they're taking more than
they're giving it's not like working in
New York and then living in New Jersey
no it's a little bit different uh next
clip it's counter-intuitive but building
a wall wouldn't stop people from coming
in it would actually stop them from
going back
no that's not true next clip the number
of illegal border crossings is actually
at an all-time low
no that's not true I have it up right
here uh Washington Examiner
illegal border crossings by children
families are surging again and we'll put
the fiscal year of 2016 on par with
2014. there's a chart for you here's why
listen at a certain point of course
immigration is going to start slowing
down because Mexico has dumped a a tenth
ten percent of its population have moved
to the United States so at a certain
point you're going to hit a a critical
mass of how many people can leave their
crappy country to a better country the
United States 10 12 maybe it'll go back
to eight it'll hover around there now
here's why this chart occurred
um because of all
actually the deportations as they've
plummeted more people have been coming
back in and now we're facing the surge
that we had in 2014. so the inverse is
true of what they've said as
deportations have plummeted as Barack
Obama tried to act and really what's
happened is people are being treated uh
more humanely they would well there's
now all of a sudden we see this you can
see this sort of like a fat caterpillar
in the graph we have a problem with
illegal immigration again of course and
the problems that come with that uh
draining on the system the problem of
the social safety net of fiscal
responsibility do we have more Clips we
have to close okay let's see the clothes
not all close oh my God Adam you're
right
the wall isn't the answer oh good I'm so
I'm so gonna Deport them
yes deportation is the answer
because of course it's racist to deport
people who've broken the law to come
here illegally again it's here's that's
that that's that sleight of hand it
starts off with will it would only help
with uh maybe half maybe 60 73 and so if
you just hear that you you don't even
think about it you're thinking you heard
10 you go wow then that's silly why
would we spend the whole NASA budget to
stop ten percent no you're spending
actually a very reasonable budget and we
can get Mexico to pay for at least a
portion of it if you look at the actual
plans and tariffs and what you can do
with the transfer of money Donald Trump
isn't completely unrealistic to get them
to pay for a portion of it you can pay
for that it's realistic and that would
deal with 60 to 70 something percent of
illegal immigration but if you don't
understand what you're hearing you go
along with them down that logic Trail
and you follow them with false stat
false stat false idea false narrative to
the point where deportation is racist
and you get to call Donald Trump or
People Like Us racist people like me who
come from legal immigrants like my mom
who learn the language who pay taxes who
are active contributing citizens because
Adam Conover told you here's something
too this idea that we don't take in
enough legal immigrants uh it's it's
just not true it's not even close fifty
percent of all immigrants since 1965
have come from Latin America 29 from
Mexico alone that's not even taking into
account people who come here illegally
who overstay visas more people have come
to the United States from Mexico than
any other country in our modern history
okay over the past 44 years they have
these numbers 6.65 million people
have emigrated legally to the United
States compared to the previous record
world world record holder Italy 4.5
million it's not even close this idea
that we don't take enough Mexicans in
Legally that it's incredibly hard more
legal people have come to the United
States from Mexico by an unbelievable
margin it can be done it's been done
from Mexico more than any other country
and of course it's been done by plenty
of other countries so building a wall
beefing up the security all you have to
decide is it worth it to spend a
relatively small amount to stop 60 to 70
percent of illegal immigration I don't
know oh I leave that to you we'll be
right back
[Music]
hey Jared what are you doing shooting
bad guys with what by AR-15 where'd you
get it
enunciate it more clearly so our
audience can hear
ar15.com that's better they sell guns
now yeah they do are they any good
they're the best we're from air15.com
you really make that sound
effects
oh there's another one
oh you shot him with what AR-15 from
where ar15.com hey how do you know
they're bad guys that Reds and burkas
that's racist
[Music]
I'm now Lester Holt finds himself in a
pickle
[Music]
hey guys what are you doing
what's that albino Indian dude I don't
know I think I think you're talking here
what's going on Brothers what what did
he even say he didn't say brother yeah I
think he did yes you you there I'm
talking to you boys my Negroes
oh yeah okay yeah no I think I
definitely gonna have to kick it yeah I
probably shoot him this has been Lester
Holt finds himself in a pickle
[Music]
foreign
Andrew Bogut coming up next a-lister
a-lister a-lister uh you're not a world
champion though you're a fan of the Cavs
so we'll I can find I can see myself
being a fan of Andrew Bogut though
especially he's not a goldfish Golden
State anymore he's in Dallas he is in
Dallas and he doesn't like the social
justice Warriors before I get to the
next issue
uh a lot of people are asking for us to
get that uh Adam Conover rant on or the
Emma Watson rant on the YouTubes
afterward as its own segment I put up a
poll before
uh okay were you happy with Donald
Trump's performance 1300 people voted in
uh less than a half hour 31 yes 40 said
no 29 said needs boy stamina
uh which of course probably means no
uh most likely yeah we gotta stop
getting the results with those
we do indeed
um
yep okay there you go that gives you you
know listen our our readers here tend to
be pretty impartial with that they
obviously would prefer Trump over
Hillary Clinton the general consensus is
he didn't do that great uh in the debate
so I don't think it does anyone any
favors to lie to yourselves about it no
it's like disciplining a child listen
you didn't do well there's there are
some changes he can make to improve if
people just tell him it's like that
corner man
of course you're kidding they're getting
beaten up yeah
beautiful keep doing
it when it's like he's losing I gotta
got a D on my report look stuck in a to
me kid yeah
it's a d just put a line in the middle
it's a baby
so uh okay anyways talking about that we
don't have video right we just we have a
video intro oh we have a video okay this
was Ariel Winter from Modern Family
um my wife loves that show I I kind of
like the show she is the worst part of
the show and I'm not just saying that
because now I can't stand her she's
always been the weak link and and I just
feel that this isn't by the way if you
have children listening we never
self-censor but I was fun enough on the
Alex Jones Show they invited me on and a
lot of people don't know how to handle
that let's not go on anyone's show
whether it's left or right and he's been
very friendly with me um even though we
disagreeing a lot his kid listens to me
listens to this program watches this
program a lot of people tell me hey my
12 year old watches or listens now we're
never going to cater to to them and
we've never done a show that's really
anything much more severe than I guess
PG-13 like we said it's just our choice
of program however there are some things
that they probably shouldn't hear if you
don't want them so this next segment
probably if your kids are in fair
warning Ariel Winter has been a subject
of a lot of discussion this week let's
roll this clip to set it up
what are we doing here oh we're running
it there on the through the computer
it's trying is it trying to load it it's
right all right let me how let me know
when it's up and when we're ready just
give me a hand signal she took some uh
revealing pictures I guess you would say
on Instagram Snapchat whatever it is and
uh people commented lots of positive
lots of negative and so it became an
entire commentary on whether the
internet is sexist and how men react to
it and about body shaming
um do we have the clip it's time to
reload it's not like it doesn't like
this clip at all all right then we just
want to go to the images yeah go the
image let's go to the image okay so this
is the image that she put up for those
listening to rest really okay look at
that picture listen there's one thing
you see when you look at that picture uh
it's a great birthday cake
fantastic they put up that picture and
it was all can you just show us the next
picture real quick just so we can see it
yep here's the next picture that she put
up on Instagram
uh okay those but what was the other one
where it was her and the little jeans
that was it was the ones I got there
it's in the video okay it's in the video
so she put up these Ultra revealing
pictures and I guess some people
commented in sexually ways and saying
hey hey you know don't worry this is
just the industry it's sexism here's the
deal it's not sexism okay let me explain
something this is actually worse it's
more unfair to men and let me give you a
little bit of a reality check okay Ariel
Winter and people think she's Brave by
the way I love how the body's shaming I
love how the body they talk about bodies
I'm like I'm proud of my body and they
take a picture where they've clearly
taken 12 takes with all the Instagram
filters let me change the shadow in the
vignette let me change the contrast no
puppy filter no puppy and and they're
doing the vacuum stomach pose like like
Frank Zane Circa Mr Olympia and body
no they're not just showing the
frumpy picture of them in a bikini from
Paparazzi it's their best possible pose
to say they're proud of their body
they're just as vain the problem with
this is it's it's vanity it's shallow
everything disguised as though it's
female Pride so she puts these pictures
people respond people say it's sexist
here's the deal if a guy says show me
your boobs is that sexist that doesn't
mean he hates women but it's at the very
least inappropriate on gentlemanly say
misogynistic sure you shouldn't do that
however if like this woman
the lady comes up or Arrow winter and
says here are my tits and a man says hmm
I approve or disapproves as you see with
comments on the internet hmm I like said
tits sorry like I said get your kids out
of the room when we're talking about
this by the way almost always if you're
showing your boobs you have to have a
big swing and a miss for the feedback to
not be positive okay we're fans of the
boobs you're grated on a curve quite
literally the feedback was from some
people hey you look great very sexual
and some people said put some clothes on
here's the deal
foreign
you're the one who sexualized it that is
what men will see you can't get angry if
they respond in a sexual way when you
say here are my tits there's nothing
unnatural no I'm not saying men should
sexually assault or act on these urges
but this was met when you upload these
pictures I'm telling you behind the
scenes with one of two reactions from
men either fathers who have daughters
across the world groaning because they
can't let their daughter follow Ariel
Winter on Instagram anymore or the sound
of personal skin on skin contact for a
bunch of teenagers in their bedrooms who
are fans of Ariel Winter we try and
whitewash this like this is a sexy
picture on Instagram or SnapChat oh they
have a picture of Ariel Winter above
their bed let me tell you how do you
have any idea how disgusting how awful
it is what teenage boys are doing with
pictures like this in their bedroom okay
look at this come on do you know it is
let's let's be real about it it's not an
art critique these people aren't looking
and examining it's masturbatorial
material for tweens who watch Modern
Family do you have any idea how
disgusting the actual physical medical
uses are for these posters that are
printed out at Kinkos and you're mad
about a comment on Instagram you have no
idea as to how disgusting the teenage
boy male mind is I'm not excusing sexual
assault at all but it's like if you put
a piece of bacon on a dog's nose and
he's the most well-behaved dog and he
sits there not saying he can eat the
bacon but you laugh or say he's a bad
dog because he's drooling at the bacon
you upload a picture of your tits here
are my titties and a guy saying hmm I
like those breasts and then you accuse
him of being sexist and then say we're
gonna stay strong no body shaming here's
an idea how about learning something how
about reading a book how about learning
to act and stop being the weakest link
on Modern Family to begin with then you
can show people your tits and accuse
them of being sexist it is so crazy and
young men are just constantly guilted it
is such a bait and trap for young men
here are my breasts and then they
reprimand young men for liking that they
get to look at breasts of course
older men like looking at breasts
but that's feminism now sexualize
yourself and blame The Men Who react
sexually uh Andrew Bogut Andrew Bogut
coming up next this will be more fun
foreign
calls between Sean Hannity and Donald
Trump
[Music]
hello hey there Donald I just want to
make sure to tell you that you had a
great debate the polls all have you
ahead okay thanks
that's great and I want to say Donald
that you are we're definitely against
the war at Iraq ah
yep
you're definitely against the war
so uh
what are you wearing Sean what the hell
is wrong with you it's two o'clock in
the morning okay I got it sure sure I'll
I'll call back you're a great American
shut up
[Music]
all right glad to be back this guest you
know we have an a-lister here not gay
Jerry I do I don't know what happened uh
story behind it of course you can follow
him on Twitter you know who he is he's
one of the best at putting the balls in
the Hoops in the world Andrew Bogut uh
thank you for being here sir no worries
thanks for having me I can't believe
that you are here after the Fiasco that
occurred through our direct messages do
you remember that or is it just more
embarrassing for me somewhat yeah yeah
somewhere I kind of figured it was a gap
but uh no it was it was yeah it wasn't a
Jared told me he's like hey Andrew Bogut
follows you would be great to get around
the show I said okay I don't full
disclosure I don't watch basketball at
all I've since watched your your playing
very impressive
um so he goes yeah yeah he's in the
playoffs right now and he's playing
against the Cavs and then Jared said
yeah they just won talking about the
Cavs and so my message Andrew Bogut
saying hey we'd love to get you on
congrats on the big win and I get a text
from not gay Jared with the most
expletives I've ever seen you effing
idiot who blew it you blew it it's like
what am I just happened to see it before
I went to bed I'm like
oh no
they're all good wow look at my safe
space
I mean looking back if you thought that
was deliberate that would be as
brilliant a dick move as one could pull
off
yeah it was really good yeah it would
have been unfortunately it's just I'm a
total when it comes to that so
um but uh no we're glad to have you on
now I what did strike me you know I have
a bunch of like these celebrities
sometimes who follow me like why why is
Candace Cameron following me
um your Twitter profile does it say what
does it say pissing off sjw triggering
sjw yeah that's what it was for a while
um
social justice Warriors privilege was it
was exactly ah okay uh not necessarily
uh a popular move I would imagine in
today's PC Sports culture what made you
feel compelled to put that on the
profile
I just like I just like getting rolled
up I think it's
just good fun
um you know Twitter's assessed pool of
assessed pools first off um but
you know everyone's got an opinion on
something and that's that should be more
than respected but obviously with
certain people if uh
you know if your opinion is not along
their their route you're in some trouble
well it's funny one thing I will say
obviously if you detect a hint of of
accent there I believe he's Australian
truthfully Americans can't tell it it's
been Australian and New Zealand they
don't know the difference
um
there you go
um I always get the sense a lot of other
people you know from Europe they're
anti-American with Australians I've
spent a lot of time with them comedy
festivals and the like they don't seem
to have that complex it seems to be
pretty friendly am I just a silly
American or is it reciprocated oh we
definitely we definitely uh make fun of
Americans just like Americans make fun
of Australians so we have a pretty dry
sense of humor and we can you know we
you got to be able to laugh at yourself
before you can laugh at other people and
I feel like we both uh both have a good
sense of humor in that in that sense but
um very similar attitude when it comes
to that stuff and we don't really make
fun of us really you guys don't come up
that much
um
what's the restaurant the Outback I get
all that stuff all the time yes CS out
by the way have you been to Outback
Steakhouse on a scale from one to ten
how offensive is it
uh it's it's very triggering
out of there with a panic attack oh it
is awful appropriation is just
ridiculous yes I assume that the uh you
know the the Bloomin Onion is a native
dish to Australia yeah very much so yes
and it grows it grows as you see out
here amidstifier that is the blooming
onion field
um and I will say this though the social
justice because Australians are
typically going to be more liberal
anyways than Americans it's just it's
just kind of the nature so social
justice Warriors do they exist this this
politically correct offended by
everything do they exist in Australia
the same way they do here
yeah it's gonna exist everywhere I mean
that's just
um that's just the part of the world
today
um like I said if you don't agree with
what the mainstream or you know what the
majority is saying obviously uh you'll
get labeled whatever and people will say
um that you're not a nice guy or an
more than frankly okay with me Gordon
I have principles that I stick
to and I have opinions which may be
wrong or right and I expect you know
when you put an opinion out that you're
gonna you're gonna have some positives
for negatives and that's a powerful and
opinion but you know I just I just can't
I can't uh I can't relate to people that
that deny other people's right to have
an opinion and then say it's wrong when
it's simply an opinion what now how did
you come to that because you're coming
from Australia where it's obviously not
like this American right wing you're
playing in the NBA where you know most
people are obviously African-American or
people tend to lean to the left they
discipline people for being Politically
Incorrect how does an Australian
basketball player come to these
principles and opinions you must know
you're an anomaly in that sense
yeah but first off look politics and
politics I'm not left I'm not right
right I have opinions on certain issues
um but I think it's just just a matter
of being you um a lot of people you know
I tweeted a while ago whatever happened
to this election
um whichever way it goes here in the
states when we have election in
Australia you still got to get up in the
morning and go to work right you started
taking kids to school you still have to
pick kids up you still have to feed your
kids you have to go grocery shopping
um you know people that lose friends and
family over politicians and politics
um I feel sorry for those people because
it's a huge mistake those politicians
you know whatever side they're on yeah
and they don't really care about you dig
down inside you know and and that's
that's what frustrates me with the whole
system right well oh I think his video
turned off can you still hear us Andrew
Bogut
is Andrew Bogut still there did we lose
him they're bringing him back here we're
bringing back Andrew Bogut uh hold on
one second here we might have lost the
uh yeah all right there you go okay we
lost you for a second damn that hotel
internet's all great damn that jet
setting lifestyle it's almost like
you're a professional athlete so
um you're right about that it shouldn't
be that way but is that maybe where you
come in the social justice Warrior side
why they're so obnoxious because they
will cut you out just for having the
wrong opinion I mean it used to be you
could be left you could be right Free
Speech was something we all agreed on
that's not the case anymore
yeah and that's that's what what
frustrates a lot of people with that
kind of stuff um you know whether like I
said an opinion is not necessarily right
or wrong but it's someone's opinion I'd
rather know if I ask somebody if they
like me or not I'd rather than tell me
yeah I don't like you I just want to
hang out with you anymore but I don't
want to hear oh you know this that this
that and that's kind of the answer that
you have to give these days and I'm kind
of from that Old older era of just tell
it like it is and uh you know I'd rather
that know where I stand and we move on
but like I said I'm from a family that's
that's a laborious family you know that
my dad was a laborer and I grew up
around mechanical workshops and everyday
people so you know whenever I I do have
opinions it's either dollars so you know
just that's just a part of it on on
Twitter and that's why you get our fun
with it well okay so a good example
obviously this week LeBron I don't know
if you followed what what he just said
about the black lives matter
um he came out and he said you know I
respect what Colin Kaepernick did I
understand where he's coming from and I
and he made some comments saying I don't
know if my son gets pulled over what the
outcome is going to be he misused some
words created some words that didn't
exist like conversate let's be fair
um but that he he said you know but I
would stand for the anthem it's not just
about black lives matter uh they're not
all cops are bad all lives do matter we
need to come together in all lives do
matter and oh my gosh the outrage at
this have you even been experiencing
some some awake from that it seems like
that's shaking the world just saying all
lives matter from LeBron James
um I didn't see LeBron comments to be to
be quite honest with you um but look
that's that's his opinion I mean he has
every right as as Colin does not just to
staff the anthem to give his opinion and
obviously some people don't want to
agree with what he said
um but at least he's being honest you
know it's very refreshing to see that
you know he's the best athlete currently
in the world probably and our best
basketball player anyway and and to give
that opinion you know he's stepping on
some people's toes um but at the same
time you've got to respect that but he's
not even really stepping he couldn't
have been more diplomatic is my point
because if if he's being diplomatic
about it and people get mad I mean you
haven't got a shot right big tall white
Australian you're you're dead in the
water before you even speak he was
saying hey I understand Kaepernick I
understand what's happening I understand
that cops there could be some bad cops
he appealed to kind of the social
justice left talk and then he just said
but not all cops are bad and we need to
come together on this like it's not if
he just came out and said ah screw a
black lives matter I could get the
reaction but this is a reaction from
people who are Furious that he just
didn't go Full Tilt in with Sean King
and I wonder if that's if you feel like
that's common with other NBA players
because a lot of them jumped on him or
fans if that's been your experience or
if it's just the the Press blowing it up
like you said I don't really have my
opinion is not too validating it because
because I'm I'm born overseas I'm a
foreigner I mean I haven't grown up
experiencing what a lot of teammates
have taught me that experience so it's
hard for me to to get into that but like
I said I mean I just hope we get to a
point not just in America but Australia
realize that that um everyone's a human
being and hey if someone's someone's got
good qualities it doesn't matter what
uniform they're wearing or what their
skin color is that's how I look at it
you know if someone's a good person
they're a good person and I think we get
in trouble you know once we start you
know inciting violence with protests and
stuff like that I'm I'm more than
respectful of what Colin's doing because
he's doing it in a peaceful way it's
causing attention it's it's bringing it
up in the mainstream media we're talking
about it right now what I'm against is
protests that that people get hurt right
they're shot um people's businesses get
get damaged that
and you've been in both cities you were
in Milwaukee for a while and now Dallas
so you're getting the worst of both ends
of that
yeah and it's just you know there's
people that get affected by by that kind
of stuff um and deaths and meetings and
all that kind of stuff on both sides you
know the the battle that I'll get is
that police are doing that to Everyday
African-Americans that are just minding
their own business so like I said when
it comes to violence it's just so so
disappointing that that people's
families get taken away from and kids
kids are dying you know people's
businesses they're losing and that's I
don't think that's accomplishing
anything I think um right expect Colin
stance just because
at least he's got people talking and
he's and he hasn't hurt anybody you know
um well I think the end is it the NBA
Larry Elder was talking wasn't there a
guy who was fined in the NBA for not
standing for the national anthem what
Jared Blackboard yeah Blackboard he uh
Mohammed Abdul roof yeah he um that was
in the mid 90s I believe he he was he
went through all sorts and then after
that season he basically was a
journeyman he was a very very good and
very talented player
um he did that back in the day and he
you know his career was basically over
after that no one wanted to touch him
that's true and that's I mean and meta
World Peace punched guys in the face and
didn't get as much back you got Patrick
Ewing and Meadow world uh was it Metta
World data Meadow World Peace what was
it
species peace peace
about him because he's you know he might
find me but have you ever had any
run-ins with him no nothing nothing too
bad I try to that's that's probably one
of the few guys uh that I try to stay
away from we we are the same agent for a
while so we kind of had some sort of a
blunt I'd like to think um where he'd
mess with me too much I can't imagine a
six foot eleven guy shies away from too
much confrontation but I guess it
happens you think he's just crazy he got
crazy eyes you think he might go after
you
a little bit but there's there's like a
in Pro Sports there's a lot of a lot of
bravado and a lot of acting on the
cameras and the lights are on but
there's probably a handful I'd say in
the league that you know you probably
shouldn't push their buttons too much
yeah I think a lot of that goes I bet
this is this is the part Andrew bug it
never comes back in the show I think it
changes with basketball because there
isn't the same accountability as like in
hockey or Combat Sports so some guys can
hide behind you don't because I've
watched you you play you're a pretty
aggressive player you stand your ground
put it that way whereas in hockey you
punch out a fan or you talk to you're
gonna get into a fight and people are
gonna find out really quickly you don't
hide behind an agent yeah yeah which
sometimes is a good thing you know oh I
love it a quick minute in the NBA game
where you can kind of just sort things
out but uh you know that'll happen every
other every other quarter these days
nothing ever happens you know look in
our league there's a lot of holding
pushing and then everyone runs in and
then once someone runs in to hold you
back then all of a sudden you want to
run through that guy and how it goes
reality yeah I know I see that a lot and
that is where like hockey players I mean
it's not quite the level of soccer but
hockey Canadian hockey players watch it
like ah what is this like ref just let
him go let the two guys go put him in
the Penalty Box and you can't go out of
bounds yeah because I saw you though a
couple times guys uh slapping you and
getting mad just because you you know I
don't I don't know the basketball thing
but he was standing his ground and I saw
a video I don't know what some guy like
reached out and smacked me who was that
basketball
um but I'm not going to take a step back
as most guys want in our lead but you
just need to be careful that it doesn't
end up into a boxing match you know if
they start allowing too much all of a
sudden you know there was times where
there's some NBA games the 90s stood
over into the front row and that's what
the NBA obviously tries to avoid alright
we'll hold it and we will talk more
about this after Andrew Bogut uh don't
piss him off stay tuned
all right
[Music]
so I'm breaking news are louder with
Crowder I'm sorry I'm Matheson we think
you know alive to a press conference
where NBA is on LeBron James
is disgusting the current state of
police enforcement race relations and
black lives matter yeah we love you
LeBron you're the best ever
I love you so much LeBron Michael Jordan
ain't I want to get your name
tattooed
well for sure I recognize the problems
with the policing Community uh and
people like my son if they get pulled
over I'm not sure you know if that's
going to to go down in a negative way
so I understand and respect what Colin
Kaepernick is doing I will myself always
stand for the national anthem and I do
think it's important to conversate to
continue to conversate uh about this
discussion and understand it's not just
about black or white or racist riddle
all lives matter
what the the
question yeah yeah can I can I call him
a or no no no no no no no okay
that's just you okay that's fine that's
just you you Susie
[Applause]
I'll keep you abreast as the story
unfolds the louder was broader I'm part
of my husband
[Music]
nobody
and I don't want nobody
[Music]
new bump that comes to us from Pogo
remix of The Fresh Prince you're about
that age were you a fan of the Fresh
Prince
huge fan um I thought that was an
original song right there I might be
able to give you a little dance but um
used to run her from school Australia we
finish at 3 30. I used to run home to
catch it at four o'clock every day on
weekdays a great show there you go when
it was in syndication you know I was
talking about that growing up uh how old
are you Andrew
I am almost 32. okay so there you go
we're the same generation growing up
um and this this tells you that it goes
across all cultural lines you know Fresh
Prince was one of the biggest shows and
Family Matters and these were two black
families that one dad was a judge and
one dad was a cop and we just watched it
we didn't even really think about it
back then and it seems like the same
thing this wasn't a black person show it
was just the most popular show right
people loved it it turned Will Smith
into the most popular uh film actor of
all time like you talked about now
nowadays that almost doesn't happen it's
like you have the bet you have the black
programming the TBS and then this divide
do you feel like now in that case it's
it's really a shifting world for young
Millennials because of the social
justice outrage it's divided them
yeah I think I think the younger kids I
think all
feel like they need to pick a side which
you know whether you're liberal or
republican or or whatever it is
um and that that causes some problems
definitely um but yeah as a kid growing
up in Australia I didn't think twice
that the show was hilarious
um you know I'm not gonna lie I had some
uh some Wu-Tang gear and some you know
some of that kind of kind of gear back
in the day did you bring the Ruckus I
did bring the Ruckus you know I was you
know I loved it you know I just was
basketball culture obviously is a you
know hugely immersed by hip hop and rap
so right you know I love the I loved it
you know it was it was just a part of
part of growing up and I didn't think
twice about about race religion or Creed
when it came to that stuff if something
was good and I liked it it was you know
I was playing the tracks and watching
and watching the videos and Prince of
Bel-Air was number one on the list oh
yeah it was Jared but this is a nice man
it's all they have in Cleveland you have
to understand this he's clinging to a
life raft here so don't take it
personally there's another Aussie on the
team and you go to ring so
it's true oh Cleveland it's a horrible
Place uh you live in between all your
sponsors to to um so you should lose all
your sponsors for triggering me in my
safe space yes exactly this is not a
safe space in your employment in the
next couple of days
he's six foot eleven yeah but he's
really far away so give me seven foot at
least come on okay he's seven foot he's
seven foot don't piss him off this is
LeBron's not the number one it's not the
middle finger
okay we're gonna have to mute that so
you're gonna get that with the FCC so
people don't know where we are
um you know it's funny we talk about
that with with uh I won't get into the
middle World Peace thing but you
mentioned that Wu-Tang I was raised in
Canada
she was born in Detroit another terrible
Town raised in Canada and you know I
listened to Wu-Tang when my parents
found out they were horrified watch
Fresh Prince the thing is now like you
said kids should be able to but you
can't you see kids now you see stories
where kids get in trouble for listening
to Hip Hop at school because it's
cultural appropriation or if they have
Japanese food day in the cafeteria all
of a sudden there's a lawsuit because
that's considered culturally insensitive
I mean that's the social justice Warrior
thing I don't think you can have just
kids enjoy Fresh Prince and eat lo mein
because they like it someone's gonna get
offended
yeah and that's that's what we got to be
careful I think as a society because
it's never going to stop
um Melbourne is one of the most
Multicultural cities in the world I'm in
my high school alone had almost 100
different nationalities I think about
that
um and yeah it was so cool talking to
different kids
um and how they grew up with their
families the food what they did on the
weekends what clubs they were allowed to
on the weekends and what they did in
their spare time and you just learned so
much from that you get to experience so
much culture and it's it's actually
enriching you know that's why a lot of
people travel the world so I don't
understand this the whole appropriation
thing that you know it's always done in
a good positive way what's what's the
problem with it I think experiencing
other cultures is is a part of everyday
life and you know it gives you some
light values that you can't pay for in
school or university I think it's yeah
with the political correctness stuff you
know which it's just so frustrating I
know if I could interject there I just
wanted to pick his brain what's his
thoughts
he's a nice guest he took the time to do
this I know but these are the important
issues that are their partner I've never
met a bigger fan than him of LeBron just
so you know Andrew it's sad
because the best player in the world you
know yeah
yeah what are you doing this is my my
ringtone picture for you that's a low
blow that's a really low blow not kid
Jared stop it how do you sleep space
stuff right there we need to this guy is
you have some serious nerve I tell you
what when we are going to do the show on
the road at some point hashtag never
daily though uh when we go to Dallas I
will personally give you his hotel room
number and you can do with it you can
send meta World Peace if you don't want
the legal liability he's earned it he's
retired now too so you might be he might
be off for it well he's looking for work
and I think someone would pay a pretty
penny to watch this guy get as get his
ass kicked yeah it's funny you talk
about Melbourne that way
um it really is I think now it's at the
point where you can't even appreciate
different cultures and this is where you
know the social justice leftism the
political you can't appreciate other
cultures unless you say also I recognize
X Y and Z horrible things that have
happened to this culture at the hands of
you know white people and and it really
drives a wedge between people just
wanting to be human beings ironically
for people who claim to be tolerant
look man I mean my whole family's from
Croatia
um from as far back as we can go
um there's a there was a Baltimore in
1993 which was the biggest one of the
biggest bloodbaths of the last 30 40
years
um you know so Serbia versus Croatia
predominantly I've got really good
friends at a Serbian yeah this was only
two decades caused the throne you know
bombs at each other from our families
but my friend that is Serbian is a good
person and I you know I take Flack from
that from some Croatian people but so be
it I'm gonna I'm gonna if he's a good
person I'm gonna you know I'm gonna do
anything for him and and comes back to
the experiencing other cultures I'm
going to experience other cultures I
don't care what people say if they if
they think that's wrong great wow that's
what it was wrong but I'm still going to
experience other colleges check your
Croatian privilege there boguts you can
say that but you don't realize that
croatians have had it they've been
living high in the hog for far too long
yeah yeah
well just look at the NBA it's crawling
with croatians uh at Andrew Bogut thank
you so much for being with us sir and uh
hold on one moment where I'll talk to
you off air during the commercial break
louder with Crowder Andrew Bogut that
just happened mostly
[Music]
and now phone calls between Sean Hannity
and Donald Trump
[Music]
hello Mr Trump it's Sean Hannity and you
are a great American sir oh hey shut up
okay uh thanks for calling I I
appreciate it and Donald I want to tell
you that you hit the nail right on the
head with what you said at the debate
you were just as always
right on the mark
okay well frankly I've always had the
mark But what I know what I've on the
market but I want to know what do you
think about the book what are you
talking about well you were right in
that
nobody wants to call me anymore uh oh
hey shut that's not true okay your
creative American have a great one both
create a package ever wants to call you
okay I was politics I'll call you all
the time oh I know you will Trump I'm
talking about the the rest of the
journalists
they're afraid of you okay okay guys
they're afraid of you because you're
winning you're winning so much okay
frankly you're winning so much that they
don't want to have anything they know
it's going to make them look bad but I
think Melania is calling me uh Hey last
question where'd you get this no dubber
um you tweeted it out
wait you mean that wasn't a direct
message no it wasn't at reply okay I I
should I gotta go Malaya get Anthony
Weiner at the phone
[Music]
six
glad to be back we are dress really in
the third third hour third hour
Christopher Titus coming up at the uh
the bottom of the hour there
and uh we have Donald Trump coming on
relatively
what's that I thought that
the trash is supposed to come on
Wednesdays no that's uh that's Miss
Universe oh yeah safety precautions and
all safety first you can't you can never
be too careful with the safety
um okay well let's just get right into
it I guess pretty soon here uh hold on
let me bring up so I have everything
ready do we have connecting here we're
connecting do we have Mr Trump Mr Trump
are you there
uh he's not connected yet he's not
connected yet no all right let me know
when he's connected by some time here
all right let me know when he's
connected uh we're always excited
obviously to have Donald Trump there is
Mr Trump Mr Trump of course Crowder I
wouldn't miss it I gotta tell you well
listen I'm very uh very glad let's get
right into it uh how do you think you
performed this week at the debate okay I
can't tell you what
everyone else okay everyone else is
telling me they say you did such a
tremendous job people they frankly they
can't believe what a tremendous job I
did it's what it's not what I would say
it's what they're telling me it's
unbelievable so then are you saying that
you disagree with the somewhat General
consensus that um Hillary had a stronger
showing excuse me excuse me okay that's
not nice
would you say that okay I don't like it
when people say not nice things and
that's not true okay if you look at the
polls and I'm ahead of all the polls
which which pulse www
.redge report
okay I mean that's the best site
a drudge is unbelievable fantastic site
uh brightbart.com
cnbc.com Mr Trump those are hardly you
know scientific polls there will
obviously be some bias with the readers
of sites that tend to leave
okay all of them every poll okay every
single pole frankly I gotta tell you
that everybody tremendously well no some
of the more uh scientific polls are the
actual focus groups had you performing
by uh by a significant margin more
importantly I don't okay I don't those
are right all the polls are rigged never
believe the polls okay but you just said
that people should okay I didn't
want it I'm not going to say this then
don't say microphone your microphone was
rigged
yes it was it was so rigged you'll never
believed I it was crackling horrendously
oh frankly I I gotta tell you so you
think the crackling of the microphone
had an impact excuse me
then don't but they could
I was talking they couldn't hear me at
all well I mean that can sound like foul
play um I'm not sure how that would
really affect people watching on
television if you're I mean if you're
talking about it okay
and I probably sorry
you know what I won't say it well okay
then don't
I was going to say but I said Trump you
shouldn't say it was anthrax on my
microphone Anthrax Anthrax yes a very
light dusting but noticeable of
headdress can you believe it unreal no I
I don't know that I can believe that I'm
not sure but all of this okay the rig
poles the rig microphone the light
dusting of Anthrax it's all designed to
take away attach it for the fact that
Hillary Clinton okay listen
why are we talking Hillary Clinton wants
to ship all of our jobs
countries well you know that's good a
strong showing when you were talking
about jobs and trade so which country
specifically are you let's go with that
are you talking about
jaida
well China's a problem for sure but what
other countries are are concerned I'd
like to get into that yeah Steven
Scheider has better stamina
that is terrible it's terrible what
they're doing into China it's terrible
well I can definitely see how China is a
problem Mr Trump but uh you know we need
to definitely okay
okay the China is distracting from the
real issues in Americans they're frankly
they're concerned they tell me they're
concerned they're scared like what
issues let's do that okay frankly
have you seen how plugged Miss Universe
is okay no Mr Trump let's just well
actually hold on before we let you go
Alec Baldwin is set to play you on SNL
what do you think about Alec Baldwin
have you heard that sounds it yeah
okay let's get rid of Mr Trump I don't I
don't listen I I think the guy is better
than Hillary but we have to be careful
with the programming too
we have to be prudent we do he seems
Surly he does a little more than usual
if you could believe it he's usually
more chipper a little more gentlemanly
yeah than that I'm not necessarily
thrilled with how that went what do you
think about Alec Baldwin playing the old
the old Trump though I think it's so
clear with the entertainment industry
now like we talked about this they used
to say you know Vote or Die P Diddy
voted that I know people are gonna get
mad that I do the accent
um and they were saying we don't care
about who you vote for just get out and
vote now they're saying vote Hillary of
God Alec Baldwin this is a guy who
endorsed Anthony Weiner who considered
running for office this is a guy who was
a blatant hardcore leftist has
threatened to move to Canada I mean
unless you're wearing sandals you can't
count
how many times he's threatened to move
to Canada and they're bringing him in
specifically to play Trump that's not
comedy at that point that's agenda
comedy yeah like Norm MacDonald's talked
about and agenda comedy can be funny I
thought Jon Stewart was funny is a
talented guy he's one of the best yeah
he's one of the best but uh they're
bringing him in not because he's the
best Trump they're bringing him in
because he's a sting he's got a couple
opinions he's got some opinions and they
think it'll be a Sting with Donald maybe
some syllables to share speaking of
Sting this is something that's pretty
important we were talking about this we
talked last week about how Barack Obama
went in front of the U.N to say that the
United States needed to give up some of
its rights need to give up some of its
freedoms in order for the greater good
which is people misuse the term
globalist a lot or people just throw it
out there it's like well I don't like
where Trump lined up on the uh no fly no
buy you're a globalist you know no
that's not but this is an actual case if
you look at the U.N one of the biggest
examples I will harp on it until the day
I die the Kyoto Protocol that is
probably the worst obviously the
legislation right now with the internet
that Ted Cruz is fighting and Donald
Trump got in and fought with Ted Cruz
I'm really happy to see both of them
coming together on that
um so we've talked about the UN quite a
bit here is I I don't I don't know her
name so forgive me and she's very hard
to understand good luck here is the UN
what happened this week they were
talking about police brutality in the
United States and then linked it to
demanding that the United States pay
reparations try and follow it but it's
okay if you don't because obviously yes
describes again
Americans
at rest with
justice so walking will just Congress to
expedit the passing of all pending
Criminal Justice Reform bills including
so and Russia profiling act the second
chance reauthorization act and welcomes
the B parties and support for the
sentencing reform and correction Acts
with among other things proposed to
drastically reduce use of mandatory
minimum sentencing okay
uh if it was hard for you to understand
don't worry it's even harder to process
when you know what Jesus what hippie
hoarder house did it dig her out of
um I don't know I could spare them on
marijuana every year but I bet you'll
find a few cats yes
you'll find stolen library books you'll
find cats flattened like pennies in a
railroad track
she stacked boxes on top of me then
demanded reparations this is my life
hashtags so they're demanding that the
United States first I don't think the
United States should be a member of the
UN I really don't think so I don't why
if someone can tweet me when you listen
to the podcast wherever you are why
should you not what is the United States
gain from being a part of the U.N NATO I
understand the UN it's gotten to the
point now where there's no use for them
and why does the UN get to decide what
the United States does they want to talk
about and here's the thing too it just
shows the UN can be politicized it's not
true more black men are not being
targeted by police officers it's not
true that there are systemic racism in
law enforcement in the United States
white people are more likely to be shot
by police if they've committed a crime
or there's an altercation we've covered
this so it's not even factually accurate
but even if that were the case where
does the UN get off thinking they can
tell the United States that you need to
pay through reparations through all
these social programs and where where
are they you know right now where
there's their slavery still going on in
African nations in the Middle East
why aren't they talking about that
they're still throwing gay people off of
rooftops you have a lisp you're going
for a flight
why aren't they demanding reparations
from the African slave traders who stole
them and sold them into slavery I'm not
condoning slavery at all whatsoever the
United States bought slaves from African
countries and African slave Traders
multiple African countries where they
stole them from Rice paddies I mean we
did this I did this in a video at
Berkeley where they were teaching kids
about slavery and I said well hold on I
have a question they said you know when
the Americans stole these slaves from
the old world and brought them into the
new world and I said well how many of
these slaves question Professor how many
of these slaves were actually sold into
slavery they were actually made slaves
in the old world she said that's a good
question and I don't know the answer to
it she was teaching the class on slavery
that guy who was there in uh Barack
Obama when he first started the race
Wars the beer Summit that Professor uh
black guy with the fro I forgot his name
he was the one who came out and I've
written about this I'll find it
hopefully after the break and said about
90 something percent the lowest figure
is 70 something percent the vast
majority of slaves were sold into
slavery in the United States now
horrible obviously thank God we ended
slavery
thank God long before many other
countries that still
still use slavery right the U.N doesn't
have a whole lot to say about that
certainly not the grandstanding you see
here but if they're going to demand
reparations hint we're not going to
why not sit there and grandstand and
demand the African slave Traders give
that back
this just goes to show you when people
say oh uh science is foolproof no
science the theory is of course but
humans
human error is still a factor in science
when people say well international law
listen we're talking about law here this
came from the U.N doesn't matter there
are still people in the U.N there are
crazy cat ladies like this
pashmina what do you call that I don't
know I don't know maybe it's Cashmere
a crazy person like this who was
entirely ill-informed on the issue of
law enforcement she's read a black lives
matter pamphlet that was handed to her
by Sean King slipped in her P.O box and
then she's gonna sit before some
committee some trumped up silly
committee International committee and
tell the United States that hey even
though you had the bloodiest war one of
the bloodiest Wars in modern history to
end slavery even though other countries
you you need to create socialized
Healthcare to make up for your racism
it's it's silly talk we'll be back
talking about Charter Schools I think
hey Jared what are you doing shooting
bad guys with what by AR-15 where'd you
get it
enunciate it more clearly so our
audience can hear
ar15.com that's better they sell guns
now yeah they do are they any good
they're the best we're from air15.com
you really make that sound didn't have
the budget for sound of that bags
[Music]
um I don't know if you saw that the um
the never daily hashtag but I think
someone heard about the studio
all right
coming back
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
that was not K Jared's choice for a song
that's fantastic it wasn't my choice but
it's always to wake people up as we go
toward the older portion of this of the
program as we get to the boards are
tired I think where people are uh slowly
slowly fading it's gonna be a great
program Amigo never today
and Madness tanks at tone speaking of
Madness Christopher Titus will be on
after the break yep
and uh speaking of Madness also
Elizabeth Warren came out against
raising the cap on charter schools in
Massachusetts I have it up here
on my screen so this is something we
were go we were going to do a rebuttal
with John Oliver kind of like we just
did with uh
Adam Conover yeah but his stuff is
always so long I think he's funny and I
think sometimes he makes some good
points
but his thing on Charter Schools again
it's just based on this it's one of
those those things that's hard to argue
because of the bait and switch they do
it's tough to kind of nail them down to
Elizabeth Warren is is against Charter
Schools
um and the reason for it is because they
really play on on people's emotions and
they use arguments that that aren't true
and all and don't matter if it sounds a
little let me explain it to you there is
no valid argument
none against school choice or charter
schools in the United States anymore
there's none you look at very very
liberal filmmakers was it Waiting for
Superman what was that movie about uh
that talked about teachers unions this
was this is not a conservative filmmaker
um even people on the left have
acknowledged that the public schooling
system has failed this is the United
States yeah it's absolutely sucks and it
hurts the most poor Among Us
because they don't have a choice with
public schools there is not one valid
argument against school choice or
Charter Schools it is entirely supported
by big teachers unions and their DNC
cronies and this idea oh the poor
teachers union no one goes into teaching
for the money actually yes they do many
people go into public education for
decent money and incredible benefits and
very little accountability long
vacations yes it is not a system that
filters out people who shouldn't be
doing the job there are some great
teachers but there are some absolutely
horrible ones so Elizabeth Warren her
argument and any article I wrote about
it at lottery.com their main complaint
is that Charter Schools hurt but they
hurt local public schools
exactly
they should be hurt local public schools
these schools Charter Schools were
created to take kids out of those crappy
schools so of course it's going to hurt
the crappy Public Schools the only way
these Charter Schools can take kids out
of those crappy Public Schools
say it with me now is if they provide
better schooling
the only way the public schools are hurt
is if there is an alternative school a
choice that's better
so are we concerned about the school
being hurt are we concerned about the
teachers union being hurt are we
concerned about the kids welfare and
their education
so that's that's why it's hard to argue
because people go oh schools are hurt oh
no oh and they think the schools are
hurt therefore the kids are going to be
hurt the teachers are going to be hurt
no no no no no no no no and this can't
be just seen on a chart or a fact sheet
the school is hurt this school so the
child can benefit but Steve if we just
give them some more money they'll do
better right if we just give them more
money like in Detroit uh they argue
here's the thing they argue too that's a
good argument they argue that well if
these Charter Schools fail uh which
sometimes happens with Charter Schools
that's what John Oliver was talking
about they they turn abysmal and they
close up shop
that's true
and those kids sounds like it sounds
remarkable or something meanwhile the
public so it's true some Charter Schools
take advantage of the system for those
who don't know charter schools are
basically privately contracted schools
that are publicly funded so they're
given to private companies to run them
like a business is the evil world uh
evil word and sometimes they do a poor
job generally they outpace public
schools and a lot of measurable uh
standards
but let's say that's true they're
abysmal and this Charter Schools closes
up shop let's go down through all these
arguments that's true meanwhile public
schools are almost guaranteed to fail
and be just as bad as these Charter
Schools but instead of closing up shop
they fire nobody and continue to be
supported by taxpayers with no better
options for schooling
so what's better a bad Charter School
the consequences it closes and kids go
back to the crappy public school or just
starting off with the Crowley a crappy
public school that can never close where
teachers can never be fired uh they
complain that these charter schools are
run as businesses therefore
unaccountable to their Community again
these are feel arguments that they make
so it's hard to sort of it's like it's
like grabbing a bar of soap they're
unaccountable to their Community because
they're only in it for a profit motive
um what
they're just as accountable as any other
school and then some because unlike
unlike Public Schools Charter Schools if
they don't perform can go under
so their accountability is that it's
financially imperative for them to
benefit their Community or else they
cease to exist a charter they're running
it like a business the only way a
business gets to stay in business is if
they provide the service that's expected
of them charter schools are required
they are beholden to providing a better
educational experience than the public
schools or they cease to exist and the
business owner the people who run the
schools are out of a job meanwhile
Public Schools screw you they get your
money anyway
their accountability is zero none
there's no accountability let's let me
give you an example
um here's something too by the way
people don't talk about Charter Schools
this is a total rich white privilege
issue because the kids who benefit the
most are kids in inner cities who can go
to schools that aren't in their crappy
district and uh rich white liberals of
course are nearly always racist and they
don't want they want to they want to
help they want to help the people of
color from afar
Detroit people of color from if we don't
want them coming into gross points
so they get then they get mad with the
charter schools uh they hurt the most at
Ferris it really disrupts things when
they invade The Wimbledon and when they
enter the wimble them there's no better
record bottle Club of the Wimbledon I
hope you're strapped at The Wimbledon uh
let's talk about this the literacy rate
in poor urban areas Public Schools right
they don't have any other choices are
horrible in Detroit a young man is more
likely uh to end up in prison than they
are to graduate
High School
so public schools and their social
justice union-backed teachers have
failed these communities since they've
existed
it couldn't be worse and they have
plenty of money it doesn't work we know
it doesn't work
people and these kids in the work school
districts again they get the short end
of the stick nobody's even arguing it
the only argument is over the solution
so school choice conservatives
Libertarians they're advocating school
choice and rewarding Innovative
well-performing Charter Schools or
attaching a voucher to the child
Democrats like Elizabeth Warren Advocate
more money to the system that's already
failing that's it more money more money
please more money please more money
please there's no valid argument
everything that could occur in a public
school that could be in a charter school
that could be a problem occurs in a
public school and then some with zero
accountability so what's why are they so
hell-bent on destroying school choice
and just handing over more money to a
failed system well listen look at the
top political donors and look at the
public sector unions and at least the
Democrats get their job security right
screw the kid we have to help the
schools why more votes More Money More
unions
Christopher Titus oh Christopher Titus
next
[Music]
I'm now Samantha Bee says vagina
[Applause]
what will that broad say next stay tuned
for more Samantha B says vagina
[Music]
all right
we're glad to have this guest back uh I
take some proudness that everyone who's
ever been on the program with whom I
disagree right has either been back or
has wanted to come back sorry I didn't
ask you what's the best plug for you
Chris
the best plug for me uh what I've done
or what's coming up like where yeah
where should people find you uh you can
go to uh at Titus Nation on Twitter you
can go to the real Christopher Titus and
there's a new comedy special coming out
in a couple months called born with a
defect born and we're actually we're
finishing that right now okay so there
you go well Christopher Titus for those
who didn't catch on yet
um I wanted to you were talking about
off air the debate that we had on gun
control so I I literally don't think we
can call it a debate
two swinging alpha males yelling at each
other honestly if if we we both needed
orangutan fur I thought at one point
because we were just both yelling at
each other if we could have thrown poop
over Skype I think we would have it was
the stupidest we could have brought in
harambe as a moderator
exactly it was I wasn't there and you're
running a trigger and I was because
before that interview people don't know
before that interview we tried to call
Chris and he he admits he had the time
wrong and then we had to bump him when
we rearranged because we had another
guest call in late and so he was like
why is it
and I will say it was not my proudest
moment uh a lot more yelling than I
typically like and we were like we have
to bring him back yeah so I appreciate
you I appreciate you calling it and you
know I think I put her off for a while
because I was like it was so weird to
see that the responses to it there was
there was psychotic response like it's
amazing to see your extreme fans my
extreme fans and how far they will go
and what they will say and I and I
started to think I whenever I do
something like this I never want to be
part of the din you know I don't want to
be part of the I don't want to be part
of the problem which which is the idiots
on TV yelling at each other and then I
was doing it with you and I I walked
away I I didn't even care that I didn't
even care that you know whether winning
the debate losing it that didn't bother
me what bothered me was the behavior
during it it was you and I were just
screaming at each other so uh what I
just want to say that it we've got to
this place and this is this is why we're
currently in the situation now I believe
in the country with who's running for
president because the divides are so
deep so the chasm is so big and what's
gonna happen is is that so we end up and
uh come up with these extreme people
like I tell you what if Elon Musk and
Mitt Romney were running I think we'd
all be a lot happier don't you uh I'm
not a big I'm not a fan of either of
them a ton but I can see where you're
coming from like here's the thing though
that's a good good point and by the way
I like I said I I take response I was
Jared knew I was pissed off too like I
was here I was like what is he saying we
booked in three we booked them three
hours ago it's not my fault we were both
angry with Mitt Romney here's a deal
with Donald Trump they they're lobbing
out these accusations now some of the
criticism may or may not be valid
however the left has lobbed these same
criticisms and screamed them they did
the same thing with bush McCain Romney
Romney was a racist he was a sexist he
was an evil person and like you're
saying right now even though I don't
like him on some policy no one can
really believe Mitt Romney's a racist
evil bad guy no even it's funny because
my wife and I were watching the speech
he came out and gave out Trump and I I
watched the whole thing and I and it was
I had this moment of like wow this guy
seems like an adult he actually stood
for something whether stood in the face
of everybody getting mad at him on his
side right and he still he said no I
this is what I believe I'm Gonna Stand
My Ground And I thought well that's a
dude dude I may not believe him or like
him all the time but that's a dude I
could say okay I know the country's not
going to burn down and that's what that
worries me a little bit right now is
that we're we've got you know whatever
you think about Hillary at least she's
done some stuff I just again when I
watched Trump I thought oh that's being
Crowder at the debate I thought oh that
was me and Crowder he's acting like a
Crowder and uh and so I won't be doing
that to ask you a question I gotta ask
you can I ask you a question I want to
ask you a question yeah uh I you know
believe me and I don't believe you at
all that was our drinking game
drinking game was every time he mentions
China Mexico says frankly truthfully
believe me and not gay Jared is not a
big man and he was hammered absolutely
hammered was not I would have been
here's the thing anybody who has to like
it's almost like he like he wants I've
never seen someone over enunciate words
except for John Lovett's character when
he was the theater guy you know yeah
China in China what are you what are you
doing did we get it are stamina you know
what probably happened is he
mispronounced it once my son walked
around school saying stamina all day you
know I was and obviously I think the
idea of Hillary is just awful Hillary
Clinton um I think you're talking about
a known serial liar corrupt politician
defined I haven't been a huge every
everyone knows I wasn't a huge uh Trump
fan in the primary I don't think he had
a great debate performance I think he
did really well in the first 15 minutes
and then ironically enough he didn't
have a ton of stamina so I don't want to
rehearse go back through this because my
audience has heard this tonight but um I
think what you're talking about is
important the screaming because it falls
on deaf ears now the screaming about
Trump because they've done it with every
Republican ever
yeah I I so here's what I got because I
agree with that and I agree the
political system right now is a pretty
much rattled and broken a little bit and
and I think I think what you have to do
is sometimes you got to suck it up
honestly there was a time remember when
Dukakis ran I I was watching to Cox and
I I can't vote for this guy I just can't
I don't like what he stands for he
doesn't really stand for anything he's
wonky I don't I don't trust with what's
going on you know with we you know the
Soviet Union just fine I don't I didn't
unders I didn't trust him I didn't trust
that he was going to handle them so I
voted for for uh for uh Bush one I did I
was like all right this guy I'm gonna
vote for this guy and I think that's
where we lose it sometimes we got to put
you got to put ideology aside and just
vote country and uh and I've done that a
couple of times where I just like that's
why I claim to be an independent I voted
for three different Republicans uh and
so and I think we all need to stop this
infighting like there's people that
won't talk if you don't believe what
they believe they're done they don't
they don't know who you're as a person
they don't know that you could be
probably their best friend and not and
not get they just cut you off that's
where
and that's why we wanted to have you
back because that was I think probably
the most contentious interview debate
we've done in the program and so
hopefully people watching can see
because if you watch the other debates
I've had in the show I think I have
enough tracker for people like oh
something Steven was mad about something
um so I think it's important for people
to see that even if you scream and you
get mad that you can come back on you're
obviously welcome and we don't hate
Christopher Titus though I think uh
voting for Hillary Clinton um is a fatal
error but
I'm actually voting against uh okay well
fatal fatal error I would not say I
would say maybe we'll put the car in the
ditch I think the other guy's a fatal
error I think I think there's a guy when
40 Years of Public Service whatever you
think happened she's had 14 different
Republican committees try to take her
down it hasn't happened and they got her
husband they got her husband on a piece
some of them had breaks go out in their
car so
I actually do a joke about the last four
candidates running for president and I
do all four I said the last four guys we
had Trump who's like this mobster
four-year-old and I mean he's got the
hands of a four-year-old and he just
says what do you want like it's crazy
you know I'd like to do my daughter what
I think he's crazy then he had Cruz and
with Cruz you could just see Cruz I'm
glad he quit because you could just see
this sentence playing and cruise his
head all the time no one's ever gonna
wipe a booger on me again no one's ever
gonna wipe a booger on me again and then
you got Hillary who you know has this
wake of bodies behind her allegedly I
say allegedly because I don't want to
end up in a suspicious one-car accident
yes sitting in the front seat you know
with trunk carpet fibers on my shirt and
a suicide note written in a language I
don't speak and then in the news today
Christopher Titus says propeller plane
went down over the Pacific and then you
have Bernie who I love Bernie but at one
point you just realize oh he's just like
a really grumpy model train enthusiast
just going dude
's on the phone I told you don't bother
me when I'm playing with my trains yes
yeah so I think I think we have to uh I
think I think I'm glad we are glad we
got to talk home I I just got to say I'm
glad we got to talk we
um we can do this again Matt I would
love to talk with you it's better to do
it this way than screaming I think
instead of a instead of a street fight
we had a tweet fight first and I think
that's the problem you you started it
I'm sitting there you were the one that
I was like okay believe me I will finish
it believe me no uh yeah no I'm glad to
have you back on okay let me ask you
this if it were like a Rubio someone
with a lot of experience polished or a
Carly fiorina versus Hillary would you
consider the other side I always
consider the other side I actually even
with Trump at the beginning listen I
believe that if you got this far there's
got to be something you have going on so
what I do because I do a podcast too the
tires podcast I do a lot of research I
go I start researching everything and I
and and I I don't research one thing I
go I I start to get this really like I
go broad because there's a lot of people
say a lot of crap they all the time yeah
um so at the end of it uh you know we
have a president he's got three rape
allegations he's got like there's this
list of stuff he's ripped off many
workers he's got 3 500 lawsuits and and
I'm not even I'm not even arguing with
you I'm just saying these are just facts
that are going on right now and at one
point I go I I don't remember ever in
our history uh Eisenhower having three
rape allegations you know I don't
remember and then Hillary's got all
these allegations too and her husband
and they were covered up and she
defended a child rapist and laughed
about it it's one thing to defend a
child rapist it's one thing years later
to suppress evidence and laugh about it
we could go through the three things
Hillary too we can go uh she supported
the senator who used to be a cake that
was 40 years ago KKK think he came and
said I he I was wrong I was wrong and
she she's actually actually that's not
that's I I understand where you're
coming from and I do think it's
irrelevant I don't think she's a racist
I don't think Donald Trump's a racist
however Robert Byrd said the n-word
repeatedly ER enunciated as recently as
2002 and he was fourth in line for the
presidency if a plane went down with
Obama Obama Biden and I think at that
time it was Pelosi so like I think that
reflects on Hillary I don't think that
reflects on Hillary that's that guy but
that's what we've lost in politics so we
whether it's whether it's Congress can't
deal with the president
um and I believe they're kind of I mean
for this for this party that just
about the Constitution all the
time
we you have to vote on the presidential
Supreme Court nominee just vote on it
yeah vote him out don't say no that's
fine but have the balls to stand up we
have a bunch of people right now uh that
won't stand up you know vote no and be
proud of it I know I don't like this guy
I'm not voting him in that's it then
it's done but people are so worried
about politically down the road what's
going to happen instead of doing their
job for us and I'd say and I said I
would say that on both sides well I
think you're right they try to paint
Republicans the party of no for a long
time and I always said you know what I'm
fine with it no we don't want a mandate
an unconstitutional mandate that people
have to purchase private insurance uh no
I was like okay I'm fine with a no on
that I'm fine with it and people if you
want to say that the party of no that's
fine I wish more people in office
congress senate judges I wish they would
vote no more often as it relates to
expanding government hey we want this
free thing no hey we want this free
thing no I'm okay with that and I think
that's something that more people if
they understood on the left especially
coming from a socialist country like
Canada that it doesn't work just because
you don't think the government can do it
efficiently doesn't mean you don't want
people to have good health care doesn't
mean you don't want them to have good
retirement doesn't mean you don't want
them to be safe you just understand that
government is not the entity that can do
it well
well you know the government has a
tendency to the problem with the
government the ideas are great the
people that what screws it up is the
people that come up with the ideas come
up with the rules and then everybody a
buddy of my has this concept called half
a glass of juice uh there's people in
the world you meet they have a glass of
juice guy the security guard in the
parking lot that's screaming at you
because your car isn't between the lines
that guy's got half a glass of juice it
doesn't really matter that your car is
an inch over the line but I guess could
you repark it sir we have to put that
guy and then you got these guys that are
really powerful people that are the
nicest people uh Dana Carvey told me
once I said tell me something about uh
about famous people he said the ones
with real talent the ones who know where
they are are the nicest people the ones
that are barely holding on half a glass
of juice he said those people will act
like Psychopaths and I think what
happens in government is we get we get
you know there's you know percentage of
people are going to be douchebags and
and on both sides and because we have
the percentage of douchebags up there
they put more regulations more
regulations that don't serve the public
but just serve their personal interests
and that's where everything starts to go
sideways if you could take human beings
and let the Skynet computers just make
the policy I think we'd be a lot better
off I know I know how that story ends
with Skynet it ends with uh it ends with
what's her name doing uh pull-ups in a
mental War than a nuclear Holocaust
that's my mom my mom was in and out of
metal institutions that movie when my
mom's I was like I wonder if Mom worked
out
oh my gosh and she did not age well you
either you either can be uh fat
and you can be skinny or you can look
young fatter people look younger for
longer so she just did not time was not
kind to her
um what's the best but we have to we
have to go I'm glad to have you back
we'll have you back longer what's the
best place again for people to find you
uh good if you wanna if you want to uh
tweet at me uh angrily uh go to Titus
Nation on Twitter uh the real
Christopher Titus on Facebook and if you
go to uh Christopher Titus TV you can
watch some of my comedy and then uh tell
me how bad I suck yes well they will
know they will no doubt do that and uh
the worst place in the world is the
YouTube comment section so Christopher
Titus thank you for being with us sir
and the people who are going to comment
or tweet uh keep it civil you can make
fun of some things like his appearance
or how white his teeth are but don't get
personal unlike I hate these teeth damn
it I don't know this has gone off the
rails we'll be back we'll be back
[Applause]
and now Lester Holt receives some
disappointing news
gosh I'm I'm sorry to be the bearer of
bad news Mr Holt no that's quite all
right I can take it well I gotta tell
you the uh
person of color journalism Grant
you were close but they they went
another direction oh that's incredibly
surprising I know I know I was as
surprised as you I really thought I had
that on a deadlock yeah I know well if
you don't mind good sir could you kindly
tell me who did win yeah sure but I
don't think you're going to like it
um
Sean King oh skunked Again by Sean King
might I ask why do they give a reason
per chats yeah they did they said they
were looking to go more
Urban oh that stands to reason this has
been Lester Holt receives disappointing
news
[Music]
glad we're with you final segment that's
Hopper Crowder barking by the way for
those asking what the well wishes his
surgery went very well he seems to be
walking better doesn't he he does
immediately he
had knee surgery a while back people
asking my dog and they put this sort of
fake stabilizer
and uh what happened is once his
ligament had scarred over and his knee
had stabilized then this sort of I guess
it's like silicone and steel was loose
and it was rubbing up against And So It
causes irritation I mean his scar his
knee looks like Frank Frankenstein's
monster but uh so you'd think you'd be
in more pain he's walking better right
now yeah so good for him so that people
have been asking uh and I think his
presidential campaign will continue next
week yeah
he's eager to hit the trails get back
there I think so uh next week we have
Paul Joseph Watson Paul Joseph Watson
and uh
also contact our Booker about who else
we have okay we have a few uh oh that's
right I remember we're still waiting on
confirmation yeah I am the booker by the
way I just have no idea who yes who
could be very good uh so I know often
you know I really appreciate people
often send me these emails about the
closing segment and how it inspires them
for the week I don't know if this one so
much will inspire you but the big
picture here is important
I hope it does and it ties back into
having someone like Andrew Bogut on here
um and forever Andrew Bogut who you see
on the show listen the guy obviously the
guys wasn't making 13 million dollars
obviously he's a big name he doesn't do
any of these conservative shows yeah um
we have a lot of people who watch this
and enjoy it I think it's I like the
thing it's because we're more
entertaining than the constant shrill
Obama thanks Obama you know we're trying
to do a little bit more than that
um
but there's a greater issue at play here
we were talking about this we were
talking about Emma Watson at the un uh
demanding that they do something I don't
even know what her deal was on equal pay
and treating sexual violence as violence
as though it's not the case yet and we
need to make sure that educational
institutions are more equal in other
words demanding more of this safe space
trigger warning social justice
environment in school we saw it with
Ariel Winter talking about you should be
proud and body pride and no criticism
here are my breasts but don't comment on
my breasts people don't have the right
to talk this way how horrible
misogynistic is this they accuse you all
of being sexist we then talked about uh
the UN now coming in telling the United
States you need to pay reparations for
slavery Barack Obama went to the U.N
saying we need to give up our freedoms
for the greater good and then you have
of course Elizabeth Warren and the
entire left against Charter Schools
Choice educating yourself Illuminating
new issues new possibilities innovation
Emma Watson doesn't want it in college
the U.N and our president doesn't want
it in the United States the DNC and the
leftist movement they don't even want it
in public schools you notice a very
disturbing trend of them entirely not a
little bit entirely trying to control
the discussion and the control uh the
flow of information
that's what we've been seeing here in
the last few weeks and you see it with
the elections as well you see it with
the way they cover the elections the way
they cover the debates the way they
cover Donald Trump whether you like him
or not no one can argue that their
treatment of him has been fair in
comparison to Hillary and you here's a
silver lining with that that's why
people like Andrew Bogut who are in the
NBA
part of the full court Sports press
where it is just you know let's give
let's give Caitlyn Jenner an award for
uh winning the triathlon as Bruce it is
so far left for a long time people
didn't feel like they could speak up for
a long time people didn't feel like they
could ever come on a program like this
and that's changed when the left is so
overbearing and trying to control
everything it makes it okay for you to
push back a little more and that's the
no one's going to blame you no one's now
I understand conservatives out there
it's easy to get depressed because you
never have a safe space right the entire
educational world is a safe space for
liberals Hollywood we've talked about is
one big safe space for liberals as a
conservative you never get that a safe
space is basically a place where ideas
go completely untested
all right save space don't say things I
don't like you never get that as a
Libertarian conservative uh
constitutionalist Federalist whatever
you want to call yourself you don't get
that benefit and what do you have you
see now not to interrupt but what you
see now is not not colleges and
universities preparing students for the
real real world they're creating their
own fake World their own uh they're
they're molding into how they want and
they say now go make the real world go
force it to be like this safe space and
it doesn't work it doesn't work it
doesn't work it doesn't work and that's
why it's not reality no we see it with
all child actors yeah we see it with
people in Hollywood the real world kicks
their teeth in and you see that
happening with college students when
they get in the real world even people
who would pull the lever for Hillary
Clinton don't tolerate them a whole lot
so if you're and and standing with
people like Andrew Bogut people out
there even LeBron James I bet you is
going to come around because he's seen
the backlash in simply saying we all
need to come together when they are so
overbearing it allows the pendulum to
swing the other way and people don't
blame you as much and here's the beauty
of that conservatives Federalists
whatever you want to call yourself I
always get Flack for the language you
are going to be so much better prepared
this this season in the United States of
entirely trying to censor speech it's
been exposed it's been exposed on
YouTube it's been exposed on Twitter
it's been exposed on Facebook it's been
exposed with the UN it's been exposed
with colleges right it's been exposed
and so the dialogue is going to start
taking place
it's going to have to now
when big names are coming out and okay
this is ridiculous people who aren't
even necessarily political like a Bogan
um the dialogue has to take place and
here's the beauty
these people these safe spacers the Emma
Watsons Elizabeth Warren's
who take your pick the Sean Kings
they're not ready for that dialogue to
take you've been having it all the time
you've been having it your entire life
because you're conservative you've had
to defend your views they never have so
you are primed and ready now when the
floodgates open and people start talking
about these issues people are no longer
afraid to be accused of being a racist
sexist misogynist xenophobic now that we
can have these conversations we all we
always were
and that's the beauty of it so it may
seem depressing if you're in college I
don't blame you you don't have that safe
space but it's like training with a
weighted bat with a weighted vest when
you get in the real world that's why
invariably people become more
conservative or conservatives are more
successful and happier in the real world
believe me college sucks they probably
get more depressed if we had statistics
on that in the real world they fare
better because while these kids have
been training their entire life to avoid
the real world
you've been preparing yourself for it
so it's okay to go through a little bit
of pain now
people out there I know we have a lot of
young kids college students expect that
but when the shackles come off when the
weighted vest comes off my God you are
going to be amazed as to how easy it is
hopefully that helps talk to you next
week
[Music]